Oh, ich bin übelst kaputt.
Voll jüde.
Noch zweieinhalb Stunden dann Bett ge- hab ich dacht mir ich komm vor allem an der Runde
an.
Obwohl ich wieder geviewbottet oder was ist hier los?
Ne nicht geviewbottet, gefollowbottet oder sowas.
Moment ich muss mal kurz Statistiken gucken.
Zahl kommt mir irgendwie komisch vor.
Nö gar nicht.
Alles gut.
Ne gar nichts.
Moin.
Ich kann noch mal kurz in meiner Mails gucken hier ob wieder Ray Channel Legends oder irgendwelche
komischen Läden hier angefragt haben.
Haben wir doch hier.
Haha die Schieler Chinesler haben wieder angefragt.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder?
Alter was ist das für ne Anfrage?
Die wollen das ich ein Klinke Kabel bewerbe.
Ein Klinke Audio Kabel.
Warum soll ich ein Klinke- ein Audiodenker?
Warum soll man da für Werbung machen?
What the fuck?
Willkommen Sie bei User Program.
Fängt schon gut an oder?
Wir laden unsere treuen Kunden ein unser Produkt jeden Monat zu...
Ich bin überhaupt nicht euer Kunde.
Ich kenne euch überhaupt nicht.
Ist es möglich dass sie uns lediglich helfen brauchen um mehr Menschen über Audio Kabel
zu informieren?
Teilen sie beispielsweise ihre Erfahrung mit wenn sie es verwenden oder teilen sie anderen
Personen mit wie sie es sollen verwenden.
Typ 1 Klinkeverteiler 3.5mm Stereo Audio Kabel 4 Punkt linken Stecker auf 4x x-Pol Bucse
Headset Splitter für Kopfhörer Lautsprecher Laptop Smartphone PS4 MP3 Player Xbox One
Handy Hi-Fi Soundsystem Heimkino So ist der Titel von diesem Ding in der Mail.
Alter die Chiener Chinesen sind wieder am Start man.
Moin.
So viel wird heute nicht passieren.
Ich bin ziemlich im Arsch.
So was haben wir denn als nächstes hier noch?
Werbung für ein Steam Game?
Okay.
Keine Ahnung was das sein soll.
Sponsorship was wollen die?
Das sind immer die besten Anfragen.
Wo einfach nur drin steht wer sie sind ohne irgendwie was Konkretes.
Da antworte ich gar nicht drauf.
Den Rest antworte ich ja mittlerweile alles.
Minus 380 Pog.
Naja.
Real shades Dankeschön für den Sub.
So jetzt hab ich auch mal wieder reingeguckt.
Tribolon Massive 33 Monate geht ja richtig ab hier.
Nice.
Stripes.
Hi.
40 Monate wird ja immer mehr.
Aber Falle hat einmal zugeschlagen.
Kommt jetzt keiner mehr raus.
Only Fans kann ich...
Nein nein nicht Only Fans Leute.
Fansly.
Sagen wir immer Fansly.
Nicht Only Fans.
Bei was?
Ach ja.
Um was zum Titel zu sagen.
Kannst kurz was gucken.
Ja.
Slayda Teddy Dankeschön für den Sub.
Filt auch am Start.
Und Janfred 75.
Massive Subscription.
Danke schön.
Jetzt gut.
Any Primers.
Also um was zum Titel zu sagen.
Der Titel ist ja.
Neuer Job am Montag?
Fragezeichen.
Postchamp.
Raketen Emoji.
Wer das nicht lesen kann.
Also Montag neuer Job.
Ja gut das entscheidet sich dann.
Eventuell.
Also ich hab jetzt.
Ich hab euch ja erzählen, dass ich mich beworben hab woanders.
Game up.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich hab euch ja erzählt, dass ich mich beworben hab und die waren auch saumäßig schnell.
Es war eh.
Sagen wir mal so hier wieder.
Autobahn Bewerbung.
Ja.
Mich hat jemand angeschrieben.
Max willst du bei uns anfangen?
Ich hab gedacht ja.
Erzähl mal.
Da hat er was erzählen.
Hat gemeint ja hier schick einfach mal Skilllist und Lebenslauf.
Hab ich Skilllist und Lebenslauf hingeschickt.
Und zwei Tage später hatte ich dann.
Zusahre so nach dem Motto ja.
Lass mal Gespräch machen.
Und jetzt hab ich Gesprächseinladung gekriegt.
Für Montag.
Das heißt Montag hab ich allen Ernstes.
Nicht wirklich.
Aber ich hab mir gesagt.
Ja.
Ich hab mir gesagt.
Mal gucken, das erste lief tatsächlich gut leider hat es danach nicht ganz geklappt.
Mal gucken, mal gucken ob ich hier mit denen einig bin was Homeoffice und Gehalt und solche
Geschichten angeht das Gute ist bei einem agilen Startup.
Nee, es hat über 2500 Leute dort wo ich mich beworben habe.
Ich weiß nicht ob das noch als Startup durchgeht.
Leute was sagt ihr?
Ist Startup eher, also kann für euch ein 2500 Unternehmen ein Startup sein?
Oder sagt ihr Startup ist eher der Geist, also die Herangehensweise?
Oder alles über, keine Ahnung 200 Leute kann kein Startup mehr sein, wie seht ihr
das?
Also ich denke 2500 Leute ist, ja das kannst du eh nicht richtig definieren, aber 2500
Leute ist schwierig das noch als Startup durchgeht.
Mich einer fragt wo sehen sich in 10 Jahren, ich bin kein Hellseher.
Was willst du auf solche Fragen sagen?
Mit welcher Person aus dem 17.
Jahrhundert würden sie sich vergleichen?
17.
Jahrhundert das bedeutet 1600 bis 1699.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal wer in der Zeit alles gelebt hat.
Chinggis Khan.
Nein der war früher.
Ich überlege gerade was kann man sagen was definitiv niemals 17.
Jahrhundert gewesen sein kann.
Irgendetwas total bescheuertes so.
Wo jeder weiß du trollst den Jesus.
Bochis Becker.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So ein Blödsinn da.
Ich glaube nicht dass da so was kommt.
Ja denke ich auch.
Also ab einer gewissen Größe.
Habt ihr einen Tisch Kicker?
Ah ja gut ich meine ich kann ja da auch Fragen stellen.
Wer ist denn das?
Ach doch ich weiß wer das ist.
Ist es nicht der Typ mit dem Carlos wie heißt er der von Chi Tu der Chi Tu Gründer irgendwie
Party gemacht hat.
Und danach war irgendwie sein Job los.
Ich hab das nur am Rande verfolgt.
Was der ausländische Karl S.
Ist das so.
Wie gesagt ich kenn mich da nicht so aus.
Keine Ahnung wer das ist.
Ich hab das nur mit Carlos.
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie hieß er denn.
Ocelot.
Der Ocelot genau.
Der war natürlich nicht auf Deutsch so ausgespalten.
Der Ocelot war das.
Manfred das Mammut.
Alter was ist denn hier los gerade.
Das ist wieder gescampt.
Das Scam Train läuft.
Zu dem Beat.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja also wie gesagt für alle jetzt dabei kommen und was zu dem Titel wissen wollen.
Ich hab montags mein zweites Vorstellungsgespräch seit 10 Jahren.
Ich bin mal gespannt was rauskommt.
Das war jetzt allerdings sehr spontan das ganze.
Nach meinem letzten Video wo ich gesagt hab ich hab keinen Bock mehr hat mich jemand angeschrieben
den ich noch von früher kenne und hat gefragt willst du bei uns anfangen hab ich gesagt
ja zeig mal erzähl mal hat er was erzählen hat gemeint schick mal Skilllist und Lebenslauf
hab ich gemacht und jetzt hab ich eine Einladung gekriegt.
Also mal gucken wie das ganze läuft.
Ich muss mir mit denen natürlich noch einig werden was Homeoffice angeht.
Homeoffice ist nahezu 100% Homeoffice.
Zu paar Termin musst du wohl vor Ort aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
1-2 mal im Jahr ist das kein großes Ding.
Aber wichtig ist halt wie gesagt 4 Tage die Woche Teilzeit arbeiten das wissen sie.
Aber mal gucken wie das mit Gehalt wird.
Weil ganz im Ernst wenn ich den Job wechsle dass ich nicht weniger haben will das ist eh
klar.
Aber ich bin eh nicht so ganz zufrieden mit dem wie sie sich da die letzten Jahre immer
rumgedrückt haben.
Klar ich hab immer mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Kohle gekriegt aber das ist ja sag mal
so mit der Berufserfahrung und dem Tätigkeitsbereich ist das gerade mal Frankfurter Durchschnittsgehalt
wenn überhaupt.
Also ich denke das darf durchaus schon ein bisschen was gehen.
Raubu macht hier wieder seine massive Sellout.
Ja wenn ich schon keine Sellouts mache muss das wenigstens der Chat übernehmen.
Der Chat ist aber eh wahnsinnig high IQ das wissen wir ja.
Bin in derselben Situation gewesen wie du diesen Montag nächsten Montag gibt es wahrscheinlich
einen neuen.
Diesen Montag?
Nein nächsten Montag.
Nächsten Montag.
Montag 14.
14. hab ich Vorstellungsgespräch.
Mit Webcam Leute.
Leaked.
Ne nicht nicht nicht als Softwareentwickler.
Wie gesagt ich mache jetzt zwar sehr viel Softwareentwicklung im Stream aber arbeiten
will ich eigentlich nicht als Softwareentwickler.
So man wird ja auch schlicht und ergreifend mit großen Projekten die Erfahrung fehlt.
Ich glaub das ist nicht so das.
Ne wieder im DevOps Bereich quasi ungefähr in die Richtung was ich jetzt auch mache.
Nur dass es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr Ansible ist als heute und alles andere ja
muss man mal gucken.
Mal schauen.
Ich weiß es selbst noch nicht genau das müssen die mir dann erklären.
Was würdest du an Gehalt verlangen?
Also ich sag 85k.
Mal gucken was die dann sagen.
Also für 5 Tage nicht für 4 Tage.
Das muss man immer.
Das hat keinen Sinn das immer auf 4 Tage Basis.
Man sagt das auf 5 Tage Basis da wissen wir alles bevor man spricht.
Azure Consultant, Azure Export.
Gibt es überhaupt Leute die wirklich Experten in Azure?
Da verschiebt sich doch jeden Tag irgendwas.
Ich hatte ein Homeoffice bis ein neuer Azubi dazukam und jetzt muss ich auch wieder vor
Ort sein.
Was hat denn das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Wollen die das zu den Ausbildes und das geht nur vor Ort oder Stream laggt?
Wo davon?
Was ist hier wieder los?
Kannst sagen nicht mal bei Microsoft blicken die da durch.
Sind die denn in Frankfurt oder komplett Remote?
Die sind nicht in Frankfurt nein die sind in oh fuck.
Wetzlar, Wetzlar, Würzburg, Wiesbaden.
Das soll ich auf jeden Fall noch mal nachgucken bevor ich da am Montag mit denen rede.
Es ist entweder Würzburg, Wetzlar oder Wiesbaden.
Ich kann es für mich mehr als irgendeine Stadt.
Halbwegs in der Nähe mit W.
Hohe und zollern Hardwin.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja also es ist irgendwie so eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden weg von dort wo ich wohne.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm weil der Job ist 100% Remote.
Vielleicht mal irgendwie ein paar Tage im Jahr aber dann muss ich mal gucken.
Wichtig ist mir nur dass das Homeoffice technisch im Vertrag steht weil wenn ich eins gelernt
habe bei meinem aktuellen Job ist dass man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann was dort
erzählt wird.
Nächste Woche wird eh interessant.
Wenn dann auch so alles kommt.
Würdest du eine Führungsposition übernehmen?
Ne das dürfen andere machen.
Ich habe jetzt schon Probleme mit dem Twitch Chat zu führen.
Was soll ich dann echte Leute hier führen?
Real Life auch noch?
Nein das würde ich auf keinen Fall machen.
Erstens bin ich glaube ich kein guter Teamleiter.
Dafür kann ich viel zu schlecht mit anderen Menschen umgehen.
Und mir würde es auch massiv auf den Sack gehen.
In alle Richtungen.
Also das wäre nichts für mich.
Ich mache lieber das was ich gut kann.
Wie gesagt Montag Vorstellungsgespräch das zweite in 10 Jahren.
Das erste lief tatsächlich gut leider hat es danach nicht anarbeitlich geklappt.
Mal gucken ich bin gespannt.
48 das klingt so schepp.
Würde ich sagen wenn schon 69k oder?
Da kann ich sagen ich verdiene 69k.
Jeder kann sich Experte nennen ja.
Das nennt sich ja auch jeder Experte.
Letztens habe ich mal ein bisschen Spaß an der Freude auf LinkedIn.
Letztens habe ich mal ein paar ehemalige Arbeitskollegen durchgeguckt.
Und Consultants und Leute die mal bei uns waren.
Ich habe so ein paar Leute durchgeguckt.
Aller was die teilweise sich da für Positionen hingeschrieben haben.
So unter Head of irgendwas geht da nichts mehr.
Wo ich mir so immer denke.
Übertreibt es halt mal nicht weil wenn du dann die Firma nachguckst.
Dann haben die irgendwie 15 Leute.
Und das ist ja schon sehr gut.
Ich mein Eindruck machen ist ja manche Position das wichtige.
Meinst du das wäre dann auch ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn du was kannst ist aber IT technisch jede Menge Kohle möglich.
Du musst halt was können und du musst was ja was auch in Demand ist.
Also was die auch haben wollen.
Und wenn es dann auch noch so ist.
Dass das was du gut kannst was ist was eben gebraucht wird.
Was es dementsprechend natürlich auf dem Skill Level dann auch nicht an jeder Ecke
gibt.
Dann kannst du ruhig schon du kannst du kannst ja schon ordentlich was sagen.
Ich mein ob sie es dann haben wollen oder nicht.
Ja muss man sich überlegen.
Aber ich habe ja eine gute Position.
Ich muss es ja nicht machen.
Ich habe ja einen Job.
Das heißt die müssen mich schon überzeugen.
Sowohl Gehaltechnisch als auch Homeoffice Technisch.
Dass ich das mache.
Bei uns gibt es ja Ende des Jahres noch mal auf höherer Ebene Führungskräftewechsel.
Das heißt vielleicht tut sich da auch was Richtung Homeoffice.
Ganz ehrlich Spoiler nein wird sich nichts tun.
Weil das die größte Boomer Führungsriege überhaupt ist.
Bis auf einen.
Falls mein alter Chef zufälligerweise zuguckt ich weiß ich weiß dass der manchmal im Stream
guckt deswegen sage ich jetzt mal was ich muss den Namen nicht sagen er weiß dass er
angesprochen ist.
Mich hat heute jemand gefragt ob ich deine Handynummer weitergeben kann die haben einen
Job für dich.
Guck mal in deine PNs.
Nur für den Fall der Fall dass du gerade zuguckst.
Ja jeder ist es wieder im Chat.
Er weiß schon dass er angesprochen ist.
Wenn er da ist.
Bei der Bahn mit zur Bahn würde ich nicht gehen.
Kann man die Farbe nicht ein bisschen weniger aufdringlich machen hier mit dem Highlight.
Warten mal.
Highlight.
Erfäuerung kann man das dann irgendwie.
Ein bisschen weniger nervig machen.
Ah ja ja schon besser schon besser.
Nicht ganz so nicht ganz so aufdringlich vielleicht.
Ja so ist gut nicht ganz so aufdringlich.
Wie gesagt ne würde ich nicht machen.
Was würdet ihr sagen ist ein gutes Galt für einen Masterstudenten der neben seinem Studium
als Entwickler.
Ich habe keinen Plassen Schimmer.
Hab ich Kami nie mit beschäftigt.
Dazu ein bisschen Zorn Office zu schicken.
Ja ok was ist wer sagt das.
Wer sagt das das so schwierig ist.
Kann man den daheim nichts beibringen oder.
Ja sehe ich auch so.
Kannst du Liste führen wie viele Twitch Emotes du im Interview sagst.
Ja aber wahrscheinlich keine.
Ne für was denn.
Modge.
Kenn ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht aber ich hab mich auch nicht beworben bis dieses Jahr.
Ich hab mich generell ehrlich gesagt Leute wisst ihr dass ich mich eigentlich gar nicht
richtig beworben habe bisher.
Ich habe im Stream ein bisschen gelästert und gesagt dass ich keinen Bock mehr hab.
Habe ich drei Anfragen direkt in der E-Mail mit einem bei einem habe ich mich ja beworben
kann man nur nicht mal sagen mit einem habe ich ein Gespräch geführt.
Das ist dann leider nichts geworden obwohl es an sich ganz gut läuft und ich habe einmal
auf YouTube gemeckert.
Insel hat mich gleich wieder jemand angeschrieben will es nicht bei uns anfangen und mit denen
habe ich am Montag jetzt ein Gespräch also wirklich beworben habe ich mich tatsächlich
auch seit über zehn Jahren nicht mehr.
Soll mir recht sein wenn es so einfach geht.
Soll ich groß Bewerbung schreiben.
Ansonsten muss ich einen Link in Account machen da habe ich aber keinen Bock drauf.
Welche Branche kannst du da was verraten.
Oh welche Branche sind die.
Wie nennt man das.
Keine Ahnung.
Soll ich mal kurz gucken.
Es ist nicht Bank das kann ich euch sagen es ist nicht Finanz.
Es ist nicht Finanzdienstleistung und sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung welche Branche das ist.
E-Commerce passt ganz gut.
Also die haben auf jeden Fall einen Online Shop aber ja.
Online online verkauf was mit Holz.
Ja das ist schön wenn du ein ein nice Gehalt hast.
Ich hoffe ihr habt alle ein nice Gehalt.
Das sehen die Leute bei LinkedIn aber nur wenn ich eingeloggt bin.
Wenn ich da einfach nur im Browser ohne eingeloggt sein drauf gehe dann nicht.
Das ist normal ich glaube alle Leute die sich irgendwie groß als Experten bezeichnet sind
in der Regel welche die die du eigentlich nicht gebrauchen kannst.
Wie gesagt ich habe keine Ahnung wer das ist.
Concat klingt wie einen Shell Befehl.
Ich weiß nicht wer das ist.
Also ich kann dir sagen die sind es nicht.
Keine Ahnung wer das ist.
Lolcat ich bin zwar schon 38 ich auch.
Ich auch möchte aber gerne nächstes Jahr eine Ausbildung als Anwendungsemblickler starten.
Ich glaube das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir hatten auch einen in der Klasse der war 30 plus damals in der Berufsschule.
Vielleicht kannst du das mit Berufsschule auch irgendwie direkt skippen.
Ich weiß nicht was es da für Möglichkeiten gibt.
Ja wenn du auf das was du aktuell machst keinen Bock hast warum nicht?
Es ist nie zu spät.
Welchen Bereich du empfehlen würdest?
Naja vielleicht ich weiß ja nicht was du jetzt gerade machst.
Vielleicht gibt es hier irgendwie einen Bereich oder eine Branche wo dir das was du vorher
gemacht hast bevor du jetzt hier diese Umschulung oder Ausbildung machst irgendwas bringt.
Kann ja sein.
Mal angenommen du warst irgendwie Altenpfleger oder Krankenpfleger oder so.
Und du gehst dann im medizinischen Bereich ist IT technisch.
Ich mein brauchst du jetzt zwar wirklich aber es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt zu wissen
wie es vor Ort dann läuft.
Also es wäre vielleicht nicht schlecht wenn es irgendwas gibt was sich da überschneidet.
Brausebude.
Danke schön für den Prime Sub.
Und wechselst du?
Weiß ich noch nicht.
Montag habe ich Vorstellungsgespräch gucken wir mal.
Wenn ich mir mit denen einig bin was Homeoffice im Vertrag und Gehalt angeht dann vielleicht
ja dann bin ich zum 31.12. weg.
Ja gut der Endpunkt hätte man nicht ins Homeoffice setzen können aber den konntest du auch
was anderes machen lassen.
Nicht nur der Endpunkt.
Der Endpunkt war gar nicht so schlimm.
Der war bloß relativ ahnungslos aber im Nachhinein hat er es ja wirklich noch richtig gut auf
die Reihe gekriegt.
Der andere Typ der bei uns im Rechenzentrum auf der Arbeit versucht hat sein illegales
Hosting zu betreiben der war deutlich schlimmer.
Habe ich auch ein Video zugemacht.
Gesetze machen ist schwierig 50% Homeoffice.
Aha.
Das muss ja nicht 50% sein.
Kann ja 49,9 sein.
Und dann wechselt ihr euch ab und dann muss jeder nur einen Tag da sein oder so.
Also die wissen das mit 4 Tage die Woche.
Ich meine 4 Tage die Woche Teilzeit ist fast keine Teilzeit außer dass sie mehr Geld bezahlen
müssen.
Das ist immer ehrlich Leute mit 4 Tage in der Woche machen das gleich wie mit Leute
mit 5 Tage in der Woche.
Das kommt auf die Firma an ob der Bewerbungsprozess Mist ist.
Also da wo ich mich aktuell beworben habe fand ich das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hab das abgeschickt Skillliste und Lebenslauf und ich hab direkt einen Link gekriegt fürs
Bewerbungsportal wo man gucken kann wie der Stand ist.
Und heute schon die Einladung für nächste Woche Montag.
Also da kann ich mich nicht beschweren.
Hast du jetzt schon bei deinem alten Arbeitgeber gekündigt?
Ne.
Ich kann erst zum Ende des Jahres kündigen und warum soll ich das machen bevor ich was
neues in der Tasche hab.
Vielleicht überlege ich mir das ja auch.
Vielleicht sage ich dann auch hier guck dir mal ich kündige und dann kommt mein aktueller
Arbeitgeber um die Ecke und sagt ach Max Homeoffice ist doch kein Problem und kriegst
auch mehr Geld.
Dann würde ich mir das auch nochmal überlegen.
Boah ne würde ich nie machen Alter.
First Level Support ist das allerschlimmste was du machen kannst.
Es gibt nur noch eine Sache die schlimmer ist als First Level Support und das ist so
End User Support.
Also so End User Support vor Ort für irgendwas.
Oder generell User Support vor Ort.
Muss ja nicht mehr End User Support.
Das ist noch schlimmer.
Muss ich beides glücklicherweise noch nie machen.
Was macht man denn wenn man das Gefühl hat dass man viel zu wenig wissen hat.
Das Gefühl ist eigentlich normal.
Ich glaube die meisten Leute die sich ein bisschen breitflächiger auskennen und selbst
Leute die sich in einem Gebiet auskennen die wissen dass sie mehr nicht wissen als
wissen.
Es geht doch letztendlich jedem.
Guck mal was wir schon alles im Stream gemacht haben.
Wir haben wirklich alles irgendwie schon mal im Stream gemacht und ich weiß objektiv gesehen
dass ich mich eigentlich ganz gut auskenne und in so 1-2 Bereichen auch wirklich gut.
Aber so wirklich mit voller Überzeugung sagen kann ich trotzdem nicht.
Die haben 15-20 Jahre Erfahrung allerdings gerade in der IT bringt ihr ja oft mal Sachen
von vor 15 Jahren oder vor 10 Jahren schon gar nichts mehr.
Ich meine was war vor 10 Jahren gerade der Hype?
Node.js oder?
Na gut das bringt ja heute immer noch was.
Nee Node.js kam ein bisschen später.
Na wobei also vor 15 Jahren kann ich dir sagen war Ruby on Rails angesagt und wer braucht
das heute noch?
So gut wie keiner.
Ja was war vor 10 Jahren?
Vor 10 Jahren war Node.js und MongoDB neu.
Da hat jeder gedacht krasser Scheiß das müssen wir verwenden.
Bringt dir heute je nachdem was du machst auch nicht mehr viel.
Wobei das ist zumindest eine Technologie die da geblieben ist.
Da würde ich mir nicht so viel Gedanken machen.
Du hast ehrlich gesagt den Vorteil aktuell, dass du aktuell das Lernst und aktuelles Zeug
lernst.
Deine älteren Kollegen wenn die nicht permanent auch dabei sind was zu lernen dann haben
die schlicht und ergreifend in 5 Jahren von dem neuen Zeug keinen Plan mehr was man dann
braucht.
Da würde ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken machen.
Ja und ich meine 15-20 Jahre Erfahrung macht halt schon ein bisschen was aus.
Wollen die dich auch in Zeitzeit?
Wie gesagt geredet habe ich ja mit denen noch nicht aber die wissen es, dass ich nur 4 Tage
arbeite.
Ja aber wie gesagt 15-20 Jahre macht vor allem ein bisschen Erfahrung aus.
Also ich muss sagen eine der wichtigsten Sachen die ich gelernt habe die letzten, ich mache
das seit 2007 seit den letzten 15 Jahren über, die Sache die ich da gelernt habe ist die
mir wahrscheinlich immer was bringen wird ist dass man gut googeln kann, gut Suchmaschinen
benutzen kann.
Glaubt mir nicht jeder kann gut Suchmaschinen benutzen.
Es gibt Leute die stellen sich total unfähig an und finden nichts.
Aber Suchmaschine gut bedienen können sodass man das findet was man sucht bzw. dass man
manchmal erstmal rauskriegt was man eigentlich genau sucht das ist schwierig.
Ne Montag ist schon Beginn bei der neuen Stelle nicht Patrick.
Montag habe ich Vorstellungsgespräch.
Mal gucken ob ich mir dann einig werde mit denen was Homeoffice im Vertrag und Gehalt
angeht.
Ansonsten gehe ich einfach in die Schweiz.
Easy 30.000 K.
Oder USA.
Das ist aber schon ziemlich unterschiedlich alles oder?
Ich meine okay Koch, Metzger, Kalibri und dann lasse ich mir noch zusammen gefallen.
Dann auch Gesundheits- und Krankenflieger.
CTA weiß ich nicht was es ist.
Huttenbauer im Ba...
Was?
Ich habe keinen Plastenschirm also das ist aber sehr unterschiedlich alles ja.
Da hast du ja von so viel Zeug da an gut ob dir das jetzt im IT Bereich großartig was
bringt.
Aber gerade sag mal mal hier Koch, Gesundheits- und Krankenpfleger da gibt es bestimmt auch
im IT Bereich Unternehmen wo das sicherlich nicht ganz verkehrt ist wenn man da quasi
wie soll ich sagen so von der Front so ein bisschen Ahnung hat.
Angenommen ex Kollege von mir der ist da Meinung was hat er in seiner was hat er bei sich im
Teams stehen revolutioniert gerade den Medizinbereich.
Ja das ist auch ein bisschen übertrieben aber der hat der arbeitet jetzt für irgend so
ein Medizin was ist denn das weiß gar nicht was die herstellen.
Irgendwelche Bioinformatik gedönns ja und ja sehe ich was im Medizinbereich also da
gibt es ja noch mehr Unternehmen und da ist vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt wenn man
noch ein bisschen Ahnung von hast was wie es denn wirklich abläuft.
Aber ehrlich wenn du keinen Bock mehr darauf hast mach eine Ausbildung aus.
Wie kommst du denn von da überhaupt zum Anwendungsentwickler?
Also wie kommst du überhaupt darauf dass du Anwendung interessiert dich das also bastelst
du gerne privat programmierst du gerne oder weil man jetzt schon ganz schön auf Sprung.
Ja ist so ne was heißt keck lief ich fang dann gar nicht erst an.
Ey wenn es um Krankenhausverwaltungsprogramme und sonst was geht ohne Mist dann ist es
sicherlich nicht verkehrt wenn man irgendwie Background hat in Gesundheits und Altenpflege.
Wo arbeitest du das aktuell bei einer Bank in Frankfurt wo genau sage ich nicht.
Hast du nur ein Vorstellungsgespräch ja ne das habe ich geskippt die haben mich ja gefragt
ob ich zu ihnen will indirekt jemand den ich kenne hat mich gefragt ob ich nicht zu ihnen
will das habe ich geskippt.
Ist normal Leute ich habe ich weiß nicht wann ich es euch erzählt habe aber ich glaube
so ungefähr vor 2 2 1 2 3 Monaten.
Sagen wir mal 3 Monate wann habe ich euch erzählt dass ich einen neuen Chef bekomme
bei mir auf der Arbeit das ist bestimmt schon 3 4 Monate her oder August oder so in August
glaube.
Sagen wir mal 3 Monate das ist 3 Monate her und ich habe gesagt ich will ein Zeugnis
haben zum vorgesetzten Wechsel das ist ja eines der Gründe wo es eins gibt ratet mal
hat es meine Personal Abteilung dort wo ich aktuell arbeite denn geschafft innerhalb
von 3 Monaten mir ein Zeugnis auszustellen.
Nein natürlich nicht korrekt.
Haben sie nicht geschafft ob ich habe zuerst gesagt gibt es nicht und jetzt keine Ahnung
letztendlich ist mir es auch egal.
Noch mal von vorne bitte ich habe am Montag ein Vorstellungsgespräch nachdem ich mich
das letzte Mal in einem Video ausgekotzt habe dass mir ein paar Sachen auf den Kicks gehen
hat mich ein ehemaliger Kollege angeschrieben und hat gefragt will es nicht bei uns anfangen
ich habe gesagt erzähl mal und hat er mir erzählt fand ich hat sich dann schlecht angehört
dann habe ich Skillliste und Lebenslauf hingeschickt und jetzt habe ich eine Einladung für Montag
und jetzt mal gucken ob ich mir da mit denen einig werde.
Scheinlich agil zu sein es sagt jeder aktuell dass er agil ist.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt was ist der Tech Stack von der neuen Arbeit?
Ehrlich gesagt so genau weiß ich es nicht ich weiß es ist wohl einiges PHP.
Leute PHP ist überall ja es ist PHP habe ich schon gehört PHP Postgres Redis habe ich
auch schon gehört recht viel Ansible was Server Zeug angeht.
Mal gucken das dürfen sie mir auch am Montag erzählen was genau Sache ist.
Ich meine laut Skillliste kann ich ja einfach alles.
Wie ich schon wieder meine Skillliste nicht finde.
Leute hatte ich das hier nicht irgendwo hier.
Der Desktop ist leer ja ja ja aber Leute wenn ihr denkt es ist weg das ist jetzt alles hier
drinne ich habe es einfach nur verschoben.
Ach hier Skills das ist aber das falsche ne das ist das hier aber das ist nicht die komplette
Liste das ist nicht die komplette Liste da habe ich noch ein paar Sachen reingeschrieben.
Hast du die Skilllist in PDF konvertiert ja aber ich kann ja einfach alles also easy.
Ich habe da wirklich nur Sachen draufgeschrieben die ich also ok Flutter habe ich wieder raus
geschmissen habe ich da wirklich nicht großartig Ahnung von.
Ja haben wir sogar schon im Stream gemacht steht da glaube ich sogar drinne oder?
Ja.
Steht gar nicht drinne.
Ah doch grpc Brutobuff grpc steht auch drinne.
Laravel ich meine da stehen die bestimmt drauf wenn ich pap wenn die pap machen.
Flutter steht nicht mehr drinne das hier ist nicht das was ich losgeschickt habe ich habe
noch ein paar Sachen Wim habe ich beispielsweise auch hier nicht hier weggemacht und unter
übliche Tools geschrieben.
Ja exellent.
Gibt es gibt es den Witcher Film oder was machen die jetzt oder ist das Season 4.
Oder ist das irgendein sinnlos Film ohne Geralt dann interessiert es ja wirklich kein
so egal was auch immer Netflix mit der Lizenz macht.
Ich fand schon die Serie nicht gut also insofern naja.
Loaded Leute ich wollte eigentlich mit euch ein bisschen
noch schwärzen und Videos gucken und mal beispielsweise wollte ich auch mal schauen was ich mir für
ein iPhone kaufen jetzt ich brauche ja unbedingt ein neues iPhone ich benutze ja aktuell sondern
seit Jahren das iPhone was ich von der Firma gestellt kriege auch für zwei Faktor Authentifizierung
und sowas ich brauche ein eigenes und ich brauche eine neue Mobilfunknummer und muss
das alles umziehen.
iPhone 13 wahrscheinlich ein iPhone 14 Pro kein Plus 16,1 Zoll ist genug aber es ist
halt teuer.
Apache Web Server war vor 10 Jahren bestimmt aktuell Apache ist im Prinzip schon immer
aktuell.
Wobei man sagen muss vor 10 Jahren eher weniger die Hype Technologie jetzt ja eher vor 20
Jahren.
Ansonsten ist Apache immer noch aktuell wobei ich sagen muss ich verwende eigentlich hauptsächlich
NGX wenn ich Web Server brauche.
Ansonsten in letzter Zeit ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich Kaddi weil Kaddi einfach easy as fuck ist
was Let's Encrypt angeht und für einfache Reverse Proxy Sachen oder statische Seiten
ist Kaddi super wunderbar.
Kaddi finde ich bester Reverse Proxy slash Web Server den es gibt von der Einfachheit
halber her von der Handhabung her was anderes brauche ich nicht.
GitHub Leute brauchen Ruby ah GitHub ist immer noch in Ruby.
Twitter war auch mal eine Zeit lang in Ruby ich glaube mittlerweile ist Twitter vieles
in Java.
Ernsthaft Windows NT gut je nachdem was es ist wenn es nicht im Internet hängt ist ja
halb so wild.
Das hat Fireship in einem Video auch gesagt ok ich weiß zwar nicht mehr was ich gesagt
habe was Fireship auch gesagt hat aber dann muss es ja stimmen.
Nö warum du kannst anfangen wo du willst.
Achja hier war die Frage habe ich ja gerade beantwortet.
Ich weiß nicht in wie viel das jetzt in Deutschland betroffen hat letztendlich klar es hat weltweit
was betroffen keine Ahnung wie viel in Deutschland.
Dein Vater programmiert für Amazon und ja ich habe auch Interesse daran außerdem verdient
man da mehr so glaube ich.
Kommt drauf an wo du hingehst ja was du dann machst.
Spielst du eigentlich auch Battlefield ja wenn es mal ein gescheites Battlefield geben
würde wieder würde ich auch Battlefield mehr spielen.
Das frage ich mich auch weil Personalabteilung kann Personalabteilung schon mal nicht beruflich
machen bei uns so langsam wie die sind.
Ich habe vom Provider wo ich ganz am Anfang gearbeitet habe dort habe ich ein Zeugnis
das ist aber so ein richtig random Zeugnis aus irgendeinem Generator richtig schlecht
hat aber auch keinen mehr interessiert.
Also ich habe letztens ein Trick gehört was man machen kann von einem Consultant bei uns.
Ein Trick gehört was man machen kann wenn man ein Zwischenzeugnis haben möchte aber
der Arbeitgeber nicht will und sich raus redet.
Wollt ihr den hören?
Wie sehr der funktioniert kann ich euch nicht sagen aber wenn das Highly Paid Consultant
erzählt dann kann eigentlich ja nichts falsches dran sein.
Also der hat zu mir gesagt wenn man ein Zwischenzeugnis haben will und der Arbeitgeber sagt gibt es
nicht dann soll man der Personalabteilung oder seinem Chef sagen mein Aufgabenfeld hat
sich gewechselt und das ist was wo eigentlich streng genommen keiner nein sagen kann.
Ihr müsst sagen euer Aufgabenfeld hat sich geändert das ist auch ein Grund für ein Zwischenzeugnis
und das müsst ihr dann halt irgendwie verargumentieren warum das so ist aber da findet sich immer
was.
Das Aufgabenfeld hat sich geändert ja.
Sollte der Chef das nicht wissen?
Also ob sich euer Aufgabengebiet geändert hat?
Bestimmt.
Es hat sich mit Sicherheit auch geändert zu dem was bei euch im Vertrag steht.
Sagt euer Aufgabenfeld hat sich geändert ob es funktioniert weiß ich nicht aber klang
plausibel.
Ich würde gerne etwas in Richtung Embedded System machen war mich am fragen ob es nützlich
wäre nach der System Integration Ausbildung eine Mechatroniker ausbilden zu machen.
Nö ich würde nicht zwei Ausbildungen hintereinander machen.
Du kannst doch was als System Indicator in Embedded System machen wenn du ein bisschen
Plan hast davon und die Leute suchen.
Da musst du aber C++ programmieren das wird mich schon äußerst abschrecken.
Tisch Bagos 021 Danke schön für den Prime Sub.
Ich hab glaube ich irgendjemand noch übersehen gerade.
Irgendjemand noch subscribt hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Wer war das denn?
BICE 88 Danke schön für den Sub.
Rausebude auch Danke schön Leute Massive Subscriptions ganzen Primers heute wieder.
Wischl Studio Code PDF Exporter.
Ja kann ich.
Ich muss ein Konzept für ein Projekt schreiben Tips.
Ob darauf an was es sein soll.
Also was sie genau von dir wollen.
Hast du Erfahrung mit Progressive Web Apps?
Ja geht hab ich schon gemacht.
Hab ich sogar im Stream schon gemacht.
Was willst du denn wissen?
Hab ich schon ja.
Also eine Sache musst du bei Progressive Web Apps wissen.
Safari ist scheiße.
Also es kann durchaus sein dass das was du machen willst unter iOS nicht funktioniert.
Je nachdem.
Je nachdem was du machen willst.
Safari ist richtig kacke für PBAs.
Ah da ist er.
BICE Danke schön.
Ne hab ich nicht.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht ob ich das überhaupt mache.
Also ich warte Montag mal ab.
Guck ich was rauskommt.
Gehaltstechnisch und allem ob es passt.
Und vielleicht sagt ihr dann meine aktuelle Firma Max hier Homeoffice kein Problem und
gibt auch mehr Geld.
Dann guck ich mal was mir lieber ist der neue Job oder dort bleiben.
Ob sie es machen keine Ahnung.
Dann kündige ich vielleicht doch nicht.
Also ich lasse das mal auf mich zukommen.
Ich meine ich bin ja in einer ganz guten Position.
Ich muss ja nicht jetzt irgendwie ganz dringend was neues machen.
Aber ich muss auch nicht da bleiben wenn es mir auf den Keks geht.
Also das ist wunderbar.
Weiß ich noch nicht.
Wie gesagt Montag habe ich Vorstellungsgespräch.
Was stört dich eigentlich an Angular TypeScript?
Ähm ehrlich gesagt nix von Angular habe ich schlicht und ergreifend keine Ahnung.
Das was mich so von außen gesehen stört bei Angular ist dass es so ultra bloated aussieht.
Und es erinnert mich so ein bisschen an aufgeblasenes Oldschool Java Zeug.
Ja zig Factories und haste nicht gesehen aber kann sein dass es gar nicht so schlimm ist.
Und TypeScript habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Ich will bloß für mein Zeug meistens nicht noch einen extra Zwischenschritt haben.
Ich weiß es gibt ja diese Sache mit die Leute die TypeScript anfangen die sind damit so
glücklich dass sie nie wieder direkt Java Skript machen.
Aber meine Sachen sind meistens so überschaubar noch auch wenn sie gewisse Komplexität haben
wie so Sachen wie beispielsweise der Label Editor oder sowas.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht ob ich da wirklich schon TypeScript brauche und ich will jetzt
halt nicht noch irgendwie so eine extra Schicht dazwischen haben.
Personal Abteilung macht Badgear ja unsere Personal Abteilung ist in Dauer Badgear Zustand.
Nee muss man nicht.
Ja siehst du.
Man muss kreativ sein denkt dir irgendwas aus.
Wann gibt es Rust für Embedded gibt es doch schon.
Und Blazingly Fast.
Leute ich hab letztens gesehen hier ganz ganz große Sünde auf Reddit hat einer, nee auf
Hacker News, auf Hacker News hat einer sein neuestes äh frag mich nicht was es gewesen
ist.
Irgendwelche Tools keine Ahnung ist sein neuestes Projekt vorgestellt und er hat hingeschrieben
Blazingly Fast und am Ende war es in Java programmiert.
Das hat der Rust Taskforce auf Hacker News gar nicht gefallen.
Weil wenn wir eins wissen Blazingly Fast geht ausschließlich in Rust.
Direkt gekickt und noch schlimmer.
Ich hab gestern es ist gerade.NET Conf.
Ich hab gestern.NET Conf geguckt.
Die Keynote was jetzt ein anderer Typ ist der sich anhört wie der Gold Support Peter
vom Microsoft Gold Support aber es ist jetzt der neue.NET Chef.
Der hat.NET Benchmarks gezeigt und hat auch gesagt Blazingly Fast.
Eigentlich müsste der sofort gekickt werden.
Es gibt genau eine Sache die Blazingly Fast ist und das ist Rust.
Selbst wenn was anderes schneller ist dann ist es definitiv nicht Blazingly Fast.
Das ist schon besetzt.
Wieso ist in deiner Skillliste eigentlich Google Maps?
Äh weil es um irgendwelche Cloud Geschichten ging die ich schon gemacht habe und ganz ehrlich
Google Cloud Plattform Erfahrung.
Das einzige was ich da nennenswert gemacht habe ist nehm mal eine Vm erstellen.
Google Maps benutzt.
Allerdings nicht Google Maps hier so.
Sondern so für die Routenplana API.
In einem Routenplana die API für Reverse Geocoding oder so.
Da kann man quasi wenn man Koordinaten angucken kann was da ist und Karten und Ausschnitte
und Zeug.
Die haben die Desktop App von Teams unter Linus abgeschafft.
Ab Dezember gibt es nur die PWA.
Echt?
Ich habe noch nie Teams als Desktop App verwendet.
Ich habe Teams immer im Browser.
Wenn ich von einer API Daten hole und dann offline bin werden die abgeholt Daten automatisch
gecashed.
Nee du musst das das funktioniert brauchst du irgendwelche Webworker Sachen.
Du musst dich da schon selbst so kümmern.
Aber das beste ist wenn du willst dass deine App offline funktioniert dann musst du dir
die Sachen offline in Index.db oder sonst wo reinschreiben.
Ansonsten ist es blöd offline zu arbeiten.
Deine App braucht schon richtigen Offline Modus.
Da gibt es aber passende JavaScript Libraries dafür die das ein bisschen einfacher machen.
Ich bin auch Svelte Enjoyer.
Oh hier spricht einer der schon verwendet hat.
Go ist faster than Rust.
Go vs Rust vs TypeScript.
Das kann nicht sein.
Rust ist per Definition das einzige was Blazingly fast sein kann.
Das ist gut dann machen wir wieder ein bisschen Webentwicklung hier im Stream mal zur Abwechslung.
Gut wir haben es geschafft.
Nice Chat.
Chat durchgespielt für heute.
Du kannst auch eine komplette Regex Engine im TypeScript Typ System bauen.
Nur weil man was machen kann heißt es nicht unbedingt dass man das machen sollte.
Man kann bestimmt auch in Word Sachen programmieren oder Sachen in Kobol machen heutzutage.
Frag nicht.
Gibt es eigentlich ordentlichen Web Server in Kobol?
So was können wir uns da dann gucken?
Ich brauche mal ein bisschen Entspannungszeug angucken.
Ich kann mir heute nichts angucken wo ich mich aufregen muss dabei.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt das gleiche machen nur ohne Stream.
Es gibt übrigens was Leute was wir am Wochenende zusammen progressen müssen.
Und zwar hat jemand von euch schon mal AWS IoT MQTT verwendet?
Für jemanden der es nicht kennt für den ist das jetzt random Aneinanderreihung von Kürzeln
verstehe ich schon.
Warum habe ich eigentlich keinen Dark Reader mehr drauf?
Hat jemand schon Amazon IoT Zeug verwendet?
Weil ich habe gesehen dass Fiat verwendet AWS MQTT zum Austausch von Echtzeit Informationen
über das Auto.
Und die wollte ich gerne abhören.
Also was ist abhören?
Mitschneiden.
Da kann man dann zum Beispiel auch das Geofencing in der App verwenden.
Und das wäre ganz praktisch.
Aber ich habe mir das mal angeguckt und ich habe null gecheckt wie es funktioniert.
Also es ist irgendwie so, dass das Auto eine SIM Karte eingebaut hat mit irgendeinem IoT
Tarif drinne.
Und bei bestimmten Events schickt das Auto eben über Amazon IoT MQTT Messages raus.
Zum Beispiel wenn es voll geladen hat oder wenn es in gewisser Region betritt oder verlässt.
Also quasi Geofencing.
Du kannst beispielsweise in der Moin Twinker, du kannst zum Beispiel in der Fiat App kannst
du einstellen, wenn das Auto diesen Bereich betritt oder verlässt, dann schick eine Message.
Das dumme ist nur Fiat wieder richtig Low IQ.
Zumal es dann sogar nach 3 Jahren ein Paid Service ist.
Richtig Low IQ gewesen.
Die einzige Notification die man sich schicken lassen kann von Fiat ist in die Fiat App.
Wen juckt die Fiat App?
Die Fiat App ist das unsinnigste was es gibt.
Hätten die wenigstens einen sinnvollen Messaging Dienst den man sich da Notification schicken
lassen kann.
Wäre ja sinnvoll.
So deswegen will ich jetzt, ich will euch den Traffic von der SIM Karte mitschneiden.
Ich möchte das machen was die Fiat App auch macht.
Ich möchte mich connecten zum Fiat AWS MQTT Server von Fiat.
Dass es geht ist mir klar, weil die App kann es auch und die Zugangsdaten dazu sind habe
ich auch, weil die gibt es quasi.
Kann man in der App nachgucken.
Also das sind so temporäre Amazon Zugangsdaten kann man sich jeder, könnt ihr euch auch
ausstellen lassen.
Das ist kein Ding.
So die Sache, ich habe keine Ahnung wie man den Kram bedient.
Ich habe mir ein paar.NET Libraries davon angeguckt, ich habe nichts gecheckt.
Gar nichts.
Keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert.
Das müssen wir am Wochenende mal ausprobieren.
Stubenhocker, ja Amazon AWS MQTT.
Also Amazon AWS IoT.
Und die haben einen MQTT Server bei Amazon.
Den kann man auch beispielsweise über Websockets ansprechen und die Fiat App die benutzt das.
Und ich habe, also wie gesagt ich habe das schon komplett ausgelesen, also ich habe die
AP Keys und die Zugangsdaten und alles was man so braucht.
Ich habe ja eine Erweiterung für Home Assistant gebaut, wo man die Daten auslesen kann und
in seine Heimautomatisierung packen kann ohne dass man die offizielle App verwenden muss
damit.
Und jetzt würde ich halt gerne diese Echtzeit Infos, die das Auto über MQTT verschickt,
auch noch abgreifen.
Weil man dann zum Beispiel Geofencing machen kann mit dem Auto, so wenn das in gewisse
Regionen fährt oder rausfährt, dann kann man es ja nachgeschicken lassen.
Das ist zum Beispiel, als Beispiel wisst ihr wofür das gut ist.
Stellt euch mal vor ihr macht auf eurem Hof-Tor oder an eurem Hauseingang eine Zone, dann
meldet das Auto über MQTT, ich bin jetzt in diese Zone gefahren und dann könnt ihr
das Hof-Tor oder das Garage-Tor aufmachen.
Ja, also für sowas wäre das ganz cool.
Gehen tut's, gehen weiß ich, dass es tut, weil die App macht das auch so, aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen, AWS, SDK, Docs sind wirklich richtig eklig, da verstehst du gar nichts.
Sobald die Hälfte nicht implementiert ist, von dem was es gibt, hast du noch einen Job?
Naja, das bringt mir nichts, ich hab's in.NET gemacht.
Für.NET gibt es kein IoT SDK, das hab ich schon nachgeguckt.
Aber es gibt Beispiele, ich hab schon Beispiele gefunden wie das funktioniert, aber das ist
so unglaublich umständlich und ich hab's auch auf die Stelle nicht hingekriegt.
Das heißt, das müssen wir uns mal am Wochenende angucken wie das funktioniert.
Hast du einen neuen Job?
Ich hab am Montag ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Da gucken wir mal.
So, was können wir uns denn anschauen?
Awesome new Windows Tools you need.
Okay, lass mich raten, es ist kein Tool dabei, was wir wirklich needen.
Wir machen jetzt den Schnelldurchlauf, also was gucken wir uns an?
File, Log, Smith, ich hab keine Ahnung was das sein soll.
Text Extractor, okay, wir machen das anders.
Wir gucken uns das so an.
Das sind irgendwelche Powertoy-Dinger, who cares?
Allways on top, away, color pick, braucht keiner.
Niemand, braucht keiner.
Next, easy, haben wir schon durch.
Why do we not, nee, why don't we shoot nuclear waste into space?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich, ich rate jetzt einfach mal, wahrscheinlich ist es zu gefährlich und zu
teuer.
Das würde ich jetzt mal so pauschal von ausgehen.
Also teuer ist es auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß nicht was das Kilogramm kostet in die Erdumlauf, wobei wir wollen es ja nicht
mal in die Erdumlauf fahren, wir wollen es ja noch weiter.
Das muss damit richtig Dampf rausgeschossen werden, dass es nicht wieder runterfällt.
Jetzt gucken wir später, hier irgendwas anderes.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Your router sucks.
Router, der Router, warum sackt der Router?
Build your own instead.
Ich glaube, dass das so eine gute Idee ist für die meisten Leute, habe ich so meine
Zweifel.
Weil je nachdem was die machen wollen, fehlt halt einiges.
Ein simpler Router, also irgendeine Kiste, die ein bisschen Routing macht, reicht den
meisten Leute ja gar nicht.
Die meisten Leute wollen irgendein Multifunktionsgerät eigentlich haben.
Die wollen sowas wie eine Fritzbox im Endeffekt.
Die wollen was haben mit Deckt Basis Station, billig Nass, DSL Modem, Wifi Access Point
und alles mögliche.
Ja, das kann es in irgendeiner Art und Weise auch alles nachbauen.
Es ist nur fraglich, ob das sich lohnt.
Wenn man wirklich einen Router bauen möchte, kann man das machen, der ist dann mit Sicherheit
auch deutlich performanter als eine Fritzbox.
Die große Preisfrage ist nur, braucht man das überhaupt für daheim?
Weil ich wüsste nicht, für was.
Für die paar Ambit, die so einen Heimanwender macht?
Geschweige denn das, was die meisten Heimanwende Internetanschlüsse hergeben?
Naja, also ich weiß nicht.
Als Artikel 13 das Internet zerstörte.
Okay, wir skippen da mal kurz schnell durch.
Also sollen wir uns einen eigenen Router bauen?
Also ich denke eher nicht.
Außer, außer, from scratch mit Rust programmiert, weil dann ist er Blazingly fast.
Neues Router OS in Rust selbst programmieren.
Auf geht's.
Oder GEN2 based, weil Arch based ist out.
GEN2.
Okay, okay auf geht's.
Also wenn mein Wireless Router meine Internet Connection zur Worst Time droppt, dann ist
er vielleicht kaputt oder mein Provider baut Scheiße, was viel wahrscheinlicher ist und
da bringt mir ein selbst gebauter Router auch nichts.
Und wenn er kaputt ist, dann ist er kaputt, da hole ich mir einen neuen.
Und nochmal was ganz was anderes.
Wenn man wirklich mit diesen Heimdingern nicht zurecht kommt, ich habe bei mir auch ein bisschen
mehr Zeug am Start.
Man kann sich da schlicht und ergreifend auch Geräte kaufen, die viel können, performant
sind und man trotzdem nicht selbst bauen muss.
Ich habe beispielsweise schon seit einer ganzen Weile einen relativ günstigen MikroTik Router.
Super Geschichte.
Hat alles an Funktionen, was ich brauche.
Von ein bisschen Firewall, DNS, DACP, was man halt so braucht.
Hat PoE.
Das war übrigens der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich mir den damals gekauft habe, weil
ich das mit dem PoE hatte.
Aber darüber mache ich auch nicht alles.
Für Deckt und VoIP gedünnt habe ich immer noch eine Fritzbox neben dran hängen.
Warum sollte man sich das selbst geben?
Und für Access Points, da habe ich einfach zwei Access Points stehen.
Einen drüben im Wohnzimmer und einen unten im Keller.
Fällig aus.
Ne Router selber bauen ist in der Regel keine sinnige Idee.
Mal gucken, was sie uns erzählen.
Die Performance ist doch überhaupt nicht das Problem, als hätte irgend einer großartige
Performance Probleme mit seinem Router daheim.
Die Leute denken das vielleicht, dass sie großartige Performance Probleme haben.
Und die einzigen Sachen, wo man vielleicht wirklich was überlegen kann, waren diese
richtig schlechten Technicolor Unity Media Modem Router Dinger.
Falls sie noch jemand kennen.
Diese schwarzen Klötze.
Und selbst bei denen war das mit der Performance nicht das Problem, sondern einfach nur, dass
sie ein richtiges kacke Modem drin hatten und diese Dinger richtig kacke waren.
Performance Technik?
Okay, mal gucken.
Warum kaufen die Stores und ISP-verkaufene Router so nicht verläuflich in der ersten
Stelle?
Das ist ein Tech-Quickie.
Das sind die liebsten Tech-Tipps.
Das sind die liebsten Tech-Tipps, in denen wir die Dinge, die wir überlegen, tatsächlich
machen.
Also Bitdefender, eine Stapel in Cyrus...
Geil!
Erst macht 23 Sekunden Intro und jetzt kommt eine Runde Sellout.
Kirk Wayne.
Das Webinterface von meiner Fritzbox leckt wie Shit.
Okay.
Lekt aber deswegen deine Internetverbindung?
Das ist doch die eigentliche Frage.
Ob das Webinterface...
Das Fritzbox Webinterface, ja, das ist nicht das schnellste, aber du musst dir mal die
Hardware da drin angucken.
Und von welchem Flash, von was für...
Das ist ja jede Micro SD-Karte, Highspeed dagegen.
Das ist langsam, das stimmt.
Wobei es geht eigentlich verhältnismäßig.
Es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt mal langsam.
Die Frage ist, leckt deswegen oder hängt deswegen oder hast du Aussetzer in deiner Internetverbindung?
Nee, hast du nicht.
Sind die neuen schneller?
Eher nicht wirklich.
Ich habe auch so einen Teil, die sind nicht...
Aber deswegen leckt ja nicht deine Internetverbindung.
Okay.
Das ist korrekt, aber das ist das, was die Leute haben wollen.
Die Leute wollen ja auch nicht nur just a router.
Die wollen ein DSL-Modem oder ein Kabel-Modem, die wollen ein WLAN, die wollen Wi-Fi Access
Point, die wollen irgendeinen Billig-Nas, die wollen eine Deck-Basis-Station, die wollen
Gäste, WLAN-Gedöns und alles Mögliche.
Das ist ja das, was die Leute haben wollen.
Was heißt die bauen das ja gar nicht selbst.
Die verteilen solche Geräte ja nicht einfach, weil es ihnen danach ist, sondern weil das
das ist, was die Leute brauchen und haben wollen.
Und in der Regel sind die tatsächlich auch noch relativ stromsparend.
Switch, ja klar.
Da muss man ja auch dazu sagen.
Ein Switch, also nur weil viele Leute sagen, das ist der Router, nur weil er ein paar Aion
45 Ports hat, stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das meiste, was man da sieht, ist zum Größteil sind das Ports von irgendeinem Switch, zwischen
denen gar nicht so ohne weiteres geroutet wird.
Also insofern, mal gespannt.
Chat, Sixhead, Sixhead Frage an euch, mal gucken wer es weiß.
Was passiert?
Also mal angenommen du hast einen Router und wir gehen jetzt mal von dem einfachsten Fall
aus, der Router hat einfach nur zwei Ports.
Ja, Port 1 und Port 2.
Oder Port A und Port B.
Und ihr stöpselt an beide Seiten, also an beide Ports ein Rechner dran und packt den
ins gleiche Netz.
Also ihr habt einen Router und auf beiden Seiten kommen Rechner dran im gleiche Netz.
Also 1 und 2, 1, 6, 8, 5.0, 24 oder so.
Können die zwei Rechner miteinander reden?
Ja oder nein?
Können die sich gegenseitig pingen?
Wir reden von einem Router, nicht von einem Switch.
Du gibst den in der IP.
Jaja, du gibst den in der IP und Netz.
Nein, können sie nicht, das ist richtig.
Es sei denn der Router macht irgendwelche Magic, Autoconfig, sonst was Sachen oder sonst
was, beziehungsweise ist standardmäßig in die Ports zusammen gebridged oder was auch
immer.
Ja, dann vielleicht.
Nee, können sie nicht, weil dafür ist das Router schlicht und ergreifend nicht da.
Korrekt.
Doch.
Kannste machen.
Du musst dich dann bloß in deiner Tabelle oder aber eben in deiner Prioritätsliste entscheiden,
was wo lang geroutet wird.
Korrekt, genau.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich meine, du kannst bestimmt bei den meisten Routern einstellen, bridge die zwei Interfaces
zusammen oder mach da sonst was.
Wahrscheinlich geht das, aber wenn wir nur vom Routen ausgehen, bringt das nichts, weil
was muss gehen, dass Rechner A Rechner B pingen kann?
Das erste, was gemacht werden muss, ist Rechner A muss dann A-Request schicken, ein Broadcast
schicken.
Genau, da Twingor kennt sich aus.
Muss fragen, was ist denn die Mac-Adresse von Rechner B, damit er das einsetzen kann.
Und spätestens da hört es beim Router schon auf.
Zumal ein Router auch gar nicht so genau wüsste, was soll er denn jetzt eigentlich machen.
Das ist ein bisschen so in die Richtung, wenn er Pakete kriegt an dem Interface und
der soll das dann Routen irgendwie wieder dahin zurück oder doch zu dem anderen, ergibt
eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Weil was beim Routing passiert ist ja, dein Rechner müsste theoretisch das ja in irgendeiner
Art und Weise an den Router adressieren auf Layer 2 Ebene.
Also was passiert beim Routen ist ja, dein Rechner, also wenn du jetzt oder wenn ihr
jetzt oder wenn ich jetzt einen Rechner anpinge im anderen Netz, dann passiert folgendermaßen,
mein Rechner weiß, das Ziel liegt in einem anderen Netz.
Wenn es in einem anderen Netz liegt, dann guckt er in seine Routing-Tabelle, wie komme
ich denn dahin, in der Regel über seine Default-Route.
Dann macht er den A-Request und sagt, Default-Route Gateway, also die IP von eurem Router, wird
aufgelöst und in dem Paket, was an den anderen Rechner geschickt werden soll, steht als
Ziel-IP der andere Rechner drin, als Quell-IP die eigene, aber, und jetzt kommt der Witz,
der Unterschied zwischen wir machen direkte Zustellung oder über den Router, der Witz
ist, die MAC-Adresse vom Router wird als Destination MAC eingetragen.
IP-technisch ist das alles das gleiche an der Stelle, aber wenn es im anderen Netz ist,
dann wird die MAC-Adresse eingetragen vom Router und dann kriegt der Router das Paket,
guckt rein, sagt, hm, wo will denn das hin, was ist die beste Route dafür, ach, dahin.
Ja, also so einfach ist es nicht.
So, MAC-Adresse ändert sich aber nie vom Source, äh doch, doch, doch, die ändert sich
beim nächsten Hop, logischerweise.
Also, wenn dein Rechner was zu seinem, zum Router schickt, dann trägt, also, IP-Adresse
bleibt immer gleich, IP-Adresse bleibt immer gleich, ja, IP-Adresse ist immer Quell-IP,
Natt, Natt mal außen vor, normales Geroute, ja.
Paket muss wieder zurück, richtig, deswegen Quell-IP bleibt gleich, Ziel-IP bleibt gleich.
Euer Rechner trägt die MAC vom Router ein, Router kriegt das, guckt, wo muss es raus
und dann, wenn er es rausschickt, setzt er die Interface MAC von dem Interface, wo er
das rausschickt, als Source-MAC ein und die vom nächsten Hop, als Destination-MAC ein.
Spätestens da ist eure Quell-MAC weg.
Aber MAC-Adresse bringen dir eh nix für irgendwelches Gerute im Internet.
Und irgendwann kommt das auf diesem Weg an, auf der anderen Seite und er baut dann ein
Transport-Paket zusammen und das geht zurück.
Genau, IPs bleiben gleich und die MAC ändert sich, äh, ja mal so, spätestens wenn man
dann mit irgendwelchen Routing-Protokollen und sonst was anfängt und zwischen Unterschiede,
mag das alles ein bisschen anders sein, aber nur von der reinen Lehre her ist das so, wie
ich gesagt hab.
So, wir gucken jetzt das Video erstmal fertig.
Also, was erzählen uns der letzte hier für ein Mist?
Also, muss immer stehen geblieben.
Wireshark all didn't happen.
Archiv.
Telekom.
Wenn du es genau wissen willst, ja?
Guck dir das an, bei ungefähr 2 Minuten 35.
Ach, das ist noch ein Switch, der Router kommt erst später.
Guck's dir im Stream an.
Da kannst du dir sogar einen Packet Tracer angucken, was passiert.
Wir haben da irgendwelche BGP-Telekom-Ausfälle nachgebaut hier.
Aber da siehst du das, da siehst du genau, was passiert.
So, also angucken.
Am Dienst?
Nein, nein, nein, das Video, das ist doch von, ähm, nee, nee, nee, nee, das Stream
ist von, äh, ja, von vor eineinhalb Jahren, oder ja, vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, was da gewesen ist vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Das war das, wo irgendein, glaub ich, hat da nicht irgendein bulgarischer Provider irgendwelche
Telekom-Entkundennetze announced über BGP und deswegen war Azure gestört, weil die Antworten
nicht angekommen sind.
Irgendwas war da in der Richtung.
Ich weiß, ich krieg's gar nicht mehr genau zusammen.
Ey, schon ein bisschen her.
Okay, weiter.
Das stimmt, aber das ist ja nicht so, als hätten die Heimwander Performance-Probleme.
Dann hast du anstatt einem kompakten Gerät auf einmal acht Dinger da rumstehen.
Vor allem so einfach ist das ja auch gar nicht.
Überleg mal, in der Fritzbox ist beispielsweise ganz viel VoIP und SIP-Gedöns drinne.
Jeder, der schon mal ernsthaft was mit Telefonanlagen und SIP und VoIP machen musste, der will das
nie wieder machen.
Und irgendjemand der nur nach 15 Heimwander will garantiert auch sowas nicht selbst machen.
Na ja, gut.
Na ja, man kann sich für 50 Euro auch einen Mikrotik-Router kaufen, der alles an Features
hat, was man nur haben können möchte, selbst wenn man ein bisschen, also für den Preis,
ein bisschen basteln will.
Also macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn sich was eigenes zu bauen.
Ja, und es verbraucht auch gleich mehr Strom.
Ja, ich habe auch einen Mikrotik-Hex-POE, kostet irgendwie 60 Euro.
Wunderbar.
Ach, einfach so eine 4 Gigabit Intel Quad-Port-Karte reinmachen, gutes.
Ja, so einen da zum Beispiel.
Nein.
Also ganz ehrlich, die Standard 0815-Dinger, die laufen unter Linux perfekt.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich an kein Problem erinnern, die wir wirklich mit Netzwerkkarten
in den letzten 15 Jahren hatten, dass dort irgendwas nicht funktioniert hat.
Mit irgendwelchen Zahnkarten mal außen vor, da gab es öfters mal Probleme, aber mit publischen
Gigabit Netzwerkkarten, ne, da gibt es keine Probleme.
Klar, die Intel-Dinger funktionieren in der Regel am besten, aber das kann eigentlich
alles sein.
Ja, ich habe noch so eine Quad-Port-Karte, die ich jetzt schon mal ausprobieren möchte.
Ich habe noch so eine Quad-Port-Karte im Schrank liegen, die habe ich damals kostenlos bekommen
von unserem RZ-Umbauverantwortlichen.
Die haben damals bei uns im Rechenzentrum umgebaut und die wollten ganz viel Zeug auf den Müll
schmeißen.
Gar nicht mal so schlechtes Zeug, ja.
Ich meine, klar, dass ich mir jetzt keinen fetten Zahn-Switch mitnehmen kann, mal davon
abgesehen, was soll ich mit dem Zahn-Switch daheim, aber ich konnte damals glücklicherweise
zwei Quad-Port-Intel-Netzwerkkarten bekommen und ein paar Glasfaserkabel.
Ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig teuer gewesen, aber ansonsten wären die im Müll gelandet.
Der hat gesagt, ich nehme einfach mit, was juckt es mich.
Zumal ich es ja eher rausgerissen habe schon.
Wie viel kostet der Schraubendreher von Linus?
Alter, dafür kriegste aber schon einen richtig guten.
Dafür kriegste schon einen richtig, richtig guten.
Ich weiß ja nicht wie, aber...
Dafür kriegste fast schon ein Vera-Set.
Also jetzt nicht das super High-End-Set, aber...
Dafür kriegste fast schon ein...
Dafür kriegste ein Vera-Feinmechanik-Set.
Also, dann brauche ich kein Linus-Tech-Tips-Ding.
Also ich muss sagen, Leute, sorry, da ich immer so auf Pause machen muss, mein Lieblings-Schraubendreher
ist der hier.
Ihr erkennt sicherlich jetzt allein schon am Sound natürlich, was es ist.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Das ist ein PB Swiss Tools BP...
Alter, die Nummer von dem Ding, meine Güte.
So eine ist das.
Ja, der da.
Das ist mein absolut Lieblings-Ding.
Der fühlt sich nicht nur an, als könntest du damit quasi auch irgendwie Eiskulpturen
raushauen, wenn du willst.
Das Gute an dem ist...
Ich meine, okay, ich gebe zu, das ist nicht ganz billig, das Teil.
Das war kurz Just for Fun, mal kurz gucken, was das kostet aktuell.
Keine Angebote, nice.
Easy.
GG.
GG Eats.
Das ist die...
Ähm, dafür habe ich den nicht gekauft.
Das ist auch die Kurzvariante, glaube ich.
Zumindest, was daran sehr nice ist, der hat einen Ratschengriff und zwar einen sehr feinzahnigen
Ratschengriff und auch einen sehr leichtläufigen Ratschengriff, der aber, wenn man ihn feststellt,
nahezu keinen Wackeln und Spielraum hat.
Also er ist wirklich, wirklich gut gemacht.
Und dieses Ein- und Ausklappding hier hinten, nicht nur, dass da mehr oder weniger alles
drin ist, was man standardmäßig so braucht, die Dinger sind auch schön magnetisch und
sitzen bombenfest und sie sind schön verstaut hinten drinnen.
Also das ist mit Abstand Lieblingstool für alle Arten des Schraubens.
So.
Next.
Das haben die alles getestet.
Okay, zeig mal, schick mal Link.
Treyker, danke schön für den Sub.
Ah, das ist das Elektriker Set.
Ja, die sind auch nice.
Das Elektriker Set ist auch Pog.
Da hast du hier so einen Griff.
Ja, also ich würde mir lieber sowas kaufen.
War ein bisschen erstaunt, dass das Glasfasernetz der Telekom, welches auch von 1 und 1 genutzt
wird, ein Shared Medium ist.
Hol auch wieder am falschen Ende, spart mal, schauen sollst, wie ein Shared Medium.
Wie will man dann...
Also ich meine, du kannst verschiedene Farben benutzen da drinnen.
Aber wie willst du dein...
Ach so, ja, das ist ja mit verschiedenen Farben dann.
Aber das ist ja nicht wild.
Das ist doch nicht schlimm, macht doch nichts.
Das nutzt einfach die Leitung besser aus.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass dein Nachbar dir deine Photonen klauen würde oder so.
The best ratchet screwdriver.
Oh, das will ich jetzt nicht alles angucken.
Können wir nachher mal schauen.
Sind keine unterschiedlichen Farben.
Na ja gut, wie auch immer es gemacht ist.
Ich denke nicht, dass das vergleichbar ist mit einem Shared Medium wie bei Kabel, wo
dann abends die ganze Straße online ist und du hast anscheinend 400 MBit nur noch 80.
Aber muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Kann sein, dass es so ist, aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal das Video kurz fertig gucken, Leute.
Sonst wird das gar nichts mehr.
So angeblich wird es jetzt wild.
Okay, ich bin mal gespannt.
Also wo sind wir gerade dabei?
Okay.
Unser Optiplex ist mit einem Core i7-3770 ausgestattet
und sollte total gut für 1Gbps oder 2,5Gbps laufen.
Wenn du schneller gehen willst, sag 10Gbps,
willst du mehr CPU-Einfluss.
Also check die bekannten Spektren und
Aspirand in der Community.
Okay, Modred, guck's mir dann mal an.
Ja.
Okay Modred, guck's mir dann mal an.
OpenSense startet auf als ein Fork von PFCense und du kannst dich nicht mit einer anderen
machen.
Aber wir lieben OpenSense für...
Ist PFCense nicht irgendwie Netgear?
...subjektiv, leichter zu verwenden...
Mittlerweile?
...und mehr frequente Updates.
Zum Beispiel, auf unserem eigenen Core-Router, der Haupt-25-Gigabitmick in dem, ist noch nicht
unterstützt von PFCense.
Wenn du nach Hause gehst, nimm dir selbst eine Kopie von OpenSense aus dem offiziellen
Site.
Echt?
Die haben es geschafft eine Netzwerkkarte zu finden, die nicht supportet wird?
Das muss die 10G-Karte sein, also...
NETGATE!
Ah, nicht Netgear.
Ja gut, die Installation von OpenSense müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Ich mein, du hast mit OpenSense zumindest ein Web-Interface, was sich halbwegs gut bedienen
lässt.
Aber ernst, der 0815-Anwender, der gerade mal mit seiner Fritzbox klarkommt, der ist von
OpenSense auf jeden Fall erschlagen.
Also, fände ich, dass auch immer die gleichen Portbezeichnungen bleiben.
Ah komm, jetzt müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, wie das installiert wird.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Was macht der da jetzt?
Ist das ein DHCP oder?
Also wir müssen uns jetzt keine PFCense-Config angucken.
Ja, vor allem bietet's auch mehr Raum irgendwie Scheiße zu bauen, wenn man keinen Plan hat.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man dem Rat von Nintendo folgt und einfach alle Ports weiterleiten
soll von außen auf seine Switch, die dann am besten noch per DHCP ne IP kriegt und auf
einmal hat euer Desktop-Rechner alle Ports weitergeleitet.
Kein Witz, empfiehlt Nintendo wirklich.
Das ist ja wieder komplett unsinnliches Video, das ist einfach quasi zweimal riesen Sellout
und inhaltstechnisch ja überhaupt nichts dabei.
Das stimmt.
The
Ja und weiter?
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
Ich darf nichts sagen meine zwei access points würden neu auch 1500 euro das stück kosten aber ich bin ja nicht blöd
Und kauft die neu ich habe die bei ebay gekauft das ist zwar nicht die super krass allerneueste generation
Aber immer noch besser als mein unify zeug und ich bin super zufrieden damit
Routers, dass wir sprechen über verwechseln kann nur für wifi werden benutzt, durch eine setting genannt ap mode oder bridge mode
Aber die performanz ist meistens ziemlich nicht groß. Also unless du das mit hardware ausprobieren willst,
Wir recommenden einen standalone access point zu holen, wie diese von ubiquity oder ein meshesystem wie die tp link decker
Also nun b quity access point da brauchst du dann da jetzt noch irgendwie ein controller drauf auf dem ding da wird es aber langsam eklig
Zumal du dann auch gar nicht so den riesen vorteil von pf sens verwenden kannst der was ja glaube ich ganz gute
Config oberfläche für wlan zeug hat ich meine firewall und so kann es immer noch verwenden weil das netz ist ja das gleiche dahinter
Was nutzt du für access points ich habe aktuell
So einen
Und so einen
Ja
So habe ich den habe ich im keller
Und den habe ich oben im ersten stock hängen
Wenn die zielgruppe sein soll bastler
Leute leute die die gerne basteln glaube ich
Aber da musste auf ebay gucken ja also neu kaufen würde ich die dinger auf keinen fall weil im ernst die dinger sind neu
halt als erstens ist es nicht mehr die neueste generation und zweitens ist es viel zu teuer wenn du das überhaupt neu kaufst dann die neueste generation die kostet gleich
Du musst bei ebay gucken
So und es gibt einen trick es gibt einen trick
Es gibt einen trick ah
Ah, Sekunde ich muss noch kurz was schreiben
So also wo bin ich wo bin ich stehen geblieben
Hehehe
So also genau also was ich euch sage es gibt einen trick was ihr machen könnt wenn ihr euch diese access points wenn ihr danach access points guckt und zwar
Normalerweise ist es ja so man darf ami access points nicht in deutschland verwenden
Weil unterschiedliche boah weiß ich nicht unterschiedliche strahlung ne nicht strahlung
Unterschiedliche Strahlung nene strahlung
Unterschiedliche wie nennt man das irgendwie sende sende power sende sende ich weiß nicht wie das heißt sendeleistung ja genau
So und das darf man eigentlich nicht verwenden also darf es eigentlich kein
US access point in deutschland verwenden also entweder macht man es trotzdem und sagt wen juckts ja
Wahrscheinlich wird es keiner merken aber so als
Tipp wenn ihr euch einen von diesen access points holen wollt guckt dass es ein US access point ist weil die sind meistens billiger weil man die nur in US verwenden kann
Sowas zum beispiel ja guckt mal hier zum beispiel 230 euro ist auch ein ganz guter preis
Stellt euch mal vor ihr kauft den jetzt der kommt hoffentlich kommt er auch aus deutschland irgendwo
Okay heavy signs auf die us versandt okay das ist blöd so wenn jetzt worauf ich raus will vollkommen egal guckt dass ihr irgendwie einen halbwegs günstigen findet am besten jetzt nicht versandt aus us oder sonst was versandt aus england versandt aus deutschland wie auch immer ist ganz okay
Guck mal artikel standort deutschland europäische union weltweit machen wir machen wir weg
Hier zum beispiel wie was was auch immer manchmal muss man manchmal muss man ein bisschen gucken und jetzt zeige ich euch den trick die dinger sind region locked eisfliegt dankeschön für den sub die dinger sind region locked aber
Haha also du kannst normalerweise einen US access point nicht umstellen auf EU warum weil es ein gesetz bei den amis gibt dass wifi technologie irgendwie homeland security relevant ist oder sowas er hat ein gesetz
bei den amis gibt dass wifi technologie irgendwie homeland security relevant ist oder sowas er halt ami zeug ja und deswegen dürfen manche sachen nichts irgendwie exportiert werden oder oder manche sachen dürfen nicht angeboten werden
Just just kakona things halt aber es gibt nen trick es gibt nen github repo nämlich das hier
Der zeigt einen trick wie man doch einen US access point anlocken kann und auf deutschland stellen kann dazu muss man die firmware downcrate auf eine auf eine firmware die noch es erlaubt per sicherheitslücke eine root shell zu bekommen auf dem ding
Also hier der macht firma downcrate also das erste was wir machen ist firma downcrate
Ach ne das mit der root shell braucht man gar nicht ach ne for prey 2020 models ok das kann sein dass man das dass man das noch braucht so da muss man sich nämlich drauf einloggen
Und dann muss man das hier machen script exec und da sieht man wie highly secure dieses security ding wieder ist das ist da gibt es übrigens auch nen schönen konferenz vortrag von dem typ der das gefunden hat gibt noch mehr sicherheitslücken in den dingern
Du gehst in den script modus und du sagst exec und die escapen die pfade hier nicht richtig und du kannst einfach ne shell aufrufen
Und dann kannst du da drin machen was du willst
Und dann kannst du den country log removal und alles ist gut aber in der regel für den für den r710 braucht ihr glaube ich nur das hier und jetzt hier tragte er dann halt de ein also sprich ihr könnt die günstigeren US access points kaufen
Ja und trotzdem ist gut
Ihr müsst halt gucken wenn es mal einen gibt in deutschland aktuell ist relativ ja schlecht an einen ranzukommen wie es geht der r510 ist auch vollkommen in ordnung geht auch
Ich habe halt nen r710 gekauft weil ich eigentlich nur einen für das gesamte haus haben wollte guck mal hier findet ihr zum beispiel welche ja
199 geht geht auch vollkommen in ordnung
Es wurde von blitzbisschen teuer vielleicht geht auch absolut in ordnung
Ja vielleicht die sache ist die ich habe mir einen 710 gekauft weil ich eigentlich nur einen für das gesamte haus haben wollte aber ich habe festgestellt dass es für ganz unten im keller nicht ausreicht deswegen habe ich im keller einen r510
Und oben ein r710 allerdings das schöne ist ihr braucht keinen controller wie bei unify sondern ein access point ist quasi der master access point die anderen ziehen sich die config von dem
Also es ist quasi ein bisschen vom handling wie unify weil ihr an einer stelle nur was einstellen müsst aber ihr braucht keinen extra controller das ist ganz praktisch
Ja so siehts aus
Das hauptproblem mit den ländern sind die unterschiedlichen bänder die in den jeweiligen ländern genutzt wird senderleistung zwar theoretisch auch über die chips sind
Und das
Okay keine ahnung aber du kannst ja das ding wenn du es unlocked hast ohne probleme auf deutschland stellen
Ich glaube insofern nicht dass es unterschiedliche hardware ist weil da müssten sie erstmal unterschiedliche hardware bauen
Ich gehe davon aus dass es weltweit die gleiche hardware ist aber die ist einfach weil homeland security und und und amelogik das nicht erlaubt haben sie es einfach in der firmware gelockt mit irgendwie einem config parameter
Warum muss heute alles telegram ohne discord sein und discord ist nice telegram verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz
So jetzt jetzt wollte ich mal jetzt wollten wir uns das video fertig angucken hier von ihm
Sekunde war oder war schon hier war mal
Also das video war reichlich sinnlos bis jetzt
Will er jetzt noch ein unify controller auf das teil drauf machen oder was also ganz ehrlich da ist nur noch 15 noob daheim seine fritzbox mit Sicherheit lieber
179 bucks oder die leichte version ist nur 100 dollar
Zumal für eine wohnung ja in fritzbox wäre auch ohne probleme reicht
Also wir machen einen speedtest das ist auf dem laptop hier aber wir sollten voll gigabit bekommen und wir können die cpu usb sehen
Das ist sehr interessant
2 ping 700 800 900 megabit und wir sind nur mit 7% cpu usb
Ja und du bestätigt doch das was ich gesagt habe dass keiner so eine fette kiste braucht für seinen traffic daheim und es jede nur noch 15 fritzbox auch easy abfackeln könnte
Ich meine mehr als deine internet leitung her gibt wir es ja darüber wohl kaum machen
Also wie gesagt ich sage ja nicht dass die fritzbox in allen bereichen das beste ist was man haben kann mit Sicherheit nicht
Aber so als multifunktionsgerät muss ja nicht meine fritzbox sein kann auch in asus teil oder so sein
Aber so als multifunktionsgerät mit den funktionen was die leute daheim brauchen ist das doch super geschichte
Plus dass du sogar rudimentär smart home geschichten mitmachen kannst
Einfache sachen
Ja und brauchst jetzt erstmal 150 watt eidl oder so weil die dwrt sicherlich nichts für noobs daheim ist
Das heißt ja auch gar nicht mehr die dwrt ist ja openwrt
Zwischen durch was mal lede
Ja
Das kostet dafür kriegst du fertig ist ja egal ja ich weiß dass es so unterschiedliche dinge sind aber openwrt
Kriegt deutlich mehr liebe als ddwrt und abt
Das ist ja unsinnig
So
Das war jetzt total sinnlos warum auch immer man sich sowas bauen sollte erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht
Danke für dein video zur abschlusspunkt
Die schriftliche form in diesem video nimmt einen ganz gut die angst
Ja das schön ich hoffe du hast nicht das video geguckt wo ich mich über meine abschluss präsentation ausgelassen habe oder
Weil dann hast du eher panik wieder davor wie unfähig die hk ist aber macht dir keine gedanken
Das hat ja bei mir auch geklappt und ich glaube schlechter laufen als meine abschlussprüfung kann es eigentlich gar nicht
Ah ja gut dann ist dann ist gut wollte ich sagen ich muss dir keine gedanken machen also es schon sehr unwahrscheinlich dass es so schlecht läuft wie bei mir
Und auch das hat funktioniert also für alle die das video nicht kennen ich habe mal ein video zugemacht
Im detail könnt wenn es interessiert könnt ihr euch das angucken die unglaubliche geschichte meiner abschlussprüfung
Ja also zu lange nicht gelesen am tag meiner prüfung hat mich die hk morgens angerufen und hat gesagt ich bin durchgefallen
Und habe ich zu ihr kag gesagt wie kann das sein meine prüfung ist doch erst heute mittag irgendwie um 14 uhr oder meinten die ja ich hätte meine abschluss dokumentation nicht eingereicht
Doch habe ich ich habe sogar eine bestätigung email bekommen von euch dass ich meine abschluss dokumentation eingereicht habe und dann meinten die
Oh dann ist irgendwie der hk surfer abgekackt und hat meine doku verloren
Und dann haben sie gesagt ich soll die doku austrucken und mit hinbringen und da haben sie mein projekt zum ersten mal gesehen 5 minuten bevor ich rein bin
Dementsprechend easy war das dann auch facks ich soll es den austrucken und mitbringen
Ja
Was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes hier das gucken wir uns später an boah 54 minuten nein das gucke ich mir jetzt bestimmt nicht an
Proxmox Homeserver Walkthrough
Ok das könnte tatsächlich ganz interessant sein, ich guck mir immer ganz gerne an was die Leute so haben, wobei das die config interessiert mich ja ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
Die config juckt mich ja immer gar nicht
Was haben die denn da wieder drauf man
Wisst ihr manche manche manche Sachen verstehen, ich mein gut der hat im weg so eine Kiste und nicht wie der eine Kerl seinen Kumpanades Cluster daheim
Aber ich verstehe es teilweise nicht die Leute übertreiben es so hart daheim. Ich meine ich habe einen Job wo ich
Schon mich um tausende Kisten kümmern muss. Brauche ich denn wirklich dann auch noch einen zweiten Job um ich mein Zeug daheim zu kümmern
Ja einmal alles von Reddit Self Hosted
Die machen es teilweise viel zu kompliziert die Leute
Also wenn ich mir das so angucke ja der hat Proxmox drauf der hat in irgendeiner vm TrueNAS wo wahrscheinlich das
Freenas Forum wieder überhaupt nicht erfreut wäre das Freenas Forum erzählt ihm dann wahrscheinlich erst mal wie in einer vm und kein
ECC RAM oh nein Weltuntergang
Da hat er zig Container noch drauf und irgendwie wahrscheinlich
Ob's wahrscheinlich auch wieder und PFCenso oder so was ist wahrscheinlich viel zu kompliziert
Und erst mal NordVPN am Start easy
Was haben wir sonst noch zu gucken na ne ne please please kein kein Level Cap heute
Fünf Gründe warum C-Sharp Murks ist
30 Minuten Moment wann ist dotnet 7 Release Date das müsste doch jetzt irgendwann sein
Available Today wollte ich gerade sagen es ist gerade dotnet Conf das kam doch jetzt raus
Ok
Dotnet 7 ist rausgekommen C-Sharp ist Murks warum ist C-Sharp Murks
Den gucke ich übrigens ganz gerne
Der hat der hat interessante Videos immer
Nicht zu C-Sharp
eher generell zur Webentwicklung
Aber warum C-Sharp Murks ist kann ich mir jetzt 30 Minuten nicht angucken
Heute nicht das hat immer Hand und Fuß was er sagt muss man muss man sagen also es hat bestimmt
Es gibt es gibt einige Sachen die an C-Sharp
fragwürdig sind
Gerade was die letzten Jahre teilweise halbherzig eingebaut wurde und jetzt erst nach und nach weiter verbessert wird
Ist wo denke ich mir auch manchmal manchmal wer ist mir lieber die machen nicht jedes Jahr ein Release sondern machen zwei Jahre
Release und denken halt man drüber nach und bringen dann fertige Features
Aber gut
Der fuchtel so viel mit seinen Händen rum
Mir egal ob der mit seinen Händen rumfuchtel das
Content vom Inhalt her finde ich die Videos echt nicht nicht schlecht aber 30 Minuten C-Sharp weiß nicht aber Time Stamp
Aber wir haben Time Stamps
Okay also kurz kurz kurz wir gucken uns das Video trotzdem der nächste mal an weil ich gehe davon
Aus dass schon ein bisschen der Kontext macht umgang mit leeren Strings
Macht C-Sharp so schlimmes
Umgang mit leeren Strings
Fünf verschiedene Teile ja das stimmt es gibt übrigens mittlerweile noch deutlich mehr als fünf verschiedene Timer
Das verstehe ich auch nicht warum sie das nicht auf die Reihe kriegen es gibt der neueste Timer in dotnet ist jetzt den gibt es
Erst seit dotnet 6 glaube ich gibt noch einen neuen Timer wahrscheinlich an der sechste
Aber wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht an der achte Timer es gibt jetzt in dotnet ein Async Timer
Periodic Timer ist das Ding glaube ich
Ja es gibt jetzt noch einen sechsten Timer dafür also was bei Microsoft was bei Microsoft los ist
Mal war es ist nett ja und die Microsoft Docs sind immer noch kacke
therefore
Was bin ich da sehend bei diesem Twitter Post?
Verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Was seh ich da im Moment?
Ich habe einen neuen Trick gefunden, der mich einfachen kann.
Ein guter Trick, der einen Prozess Memory von einem Admin Prozess nicht machen kann.
Wenn du an.NET schaust, ist es nichts schwieriges für dich.
Aber das hat doch nichts mit.NET zu tun oder?
Ich habe es nur in.NET programmiert, weil dort net hat ja auch nicht mehr Rechte als
jedes andere Programm.
Oder doch?
Bei Microsoft weiß man ja nie.
Dort net kann ja auch nicht zaubern, wenn dort net den Speicher auslesen kann, können
das andere Programme auch.
Verstehe ich jetzt 200% noch nicht.
Achso, das ist ein Tool, was bei dort net mitgeliefert wird.
Naja gut, aber wie gesagt, das muss jedes andere Programm auch können.
Okay, keine Ahnung, dann bin ich zu low IQ gerade.
Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt mal wieder einen neuen Timer für dort net, dass wir jetzt den siebten
oder achten Timer haben.
Aber ganz im Ernst, wisst ihr was die beste Timer Variante ist, wenn man es eher als dependency
hat und wenn man es nicht als dependency hat, sollte man sich das überlegen.
Der Rx, der Reactive Timer, easy, beste.
Ja, nee.
So.
Oh meine Katze will rein, Sekunde.
Sie ist jetzt einfach auf Sofa und guckt da jetzt.
Ja, das finde ich ganz praktisch hier.
So was in der Richtung, guck.
Dass man einfach sagen kann, Timer und dann wie ein Subscribetick, finde ich persönlich
die angenehmste Timer-RP, die es so gibt in dort net.
Wenn man eh die Reactive Extensions irgendwie hat.
Moin Max, wie ist mit deinem neuen Job?
Schalt jetzt erst ein.
Montag habe ich Vorstellungsgespräch.
Da entscheidet sich das, ob wir uns da einig werden.
10 free software, you probably didn't know existed.
Okay, wir gucken einfach, was es ist.
Easy.
Wir wissen, dass wir es uns nicht angucken.
Android Screen Mirror, Document Viewer, File, Uninstaller.
Okay, das stimmt.
Source Code Editor.
Wait a minute.
Da gibt es so viele.
Sagt bloß er zeigt das Visual Studio Code oder was?
Brackets?
Seriously?
Sind wir schon wieder in 2015 oder was?
Was ist los, Leute?
Brackets war cool, als es rausgekommen ist mit Live Editing von HTML Seiten und sowas.
War schon nice.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Aber mit, ich glaube, das wird doch gar nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, oder?
Ja.
Das ist archivt seit einem Jahr, eineinhalb Jahren.
Wird überhaupt nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Ja, nice.
Gut, dass er uns was empfiehlt, was eigentlich dead ist.
Hi IQ Video.
Ist schon teilweise viel Schrott auf YouTube, muss man echt sagen.
Okay, sagt jetzt nichts zu dem restlichen Video.
Ist Fang fucked?
Guck mal, was Fireship dazu erzählt.
Er kann auch gleich Atom recommenden.
Das müssen wir nicht mehr gucken, das ist outdated.
Wow, schrei nicht so rum.
Guck uns das an.
Schau mal, wie der Air.
Können wir uns Fireship angucken.
Nee, wir gucken uns gleich, wir gucken uns das.
Okay, wir gucken uns Fireship an, danach gucken wir uns das kurz gesagt Video an.
Eigentlich interessiert es mich nicht, ob die Leute gefeuert haben oder nicht.
Das ist doch, das ist Ami Logik.
Einfach massig einstellen, dann wieder massig feiern.
Ich hab gehört, das hab ich gelesen in irgendeinem News Post, dass Sazook sinngemäß erzählt
hat.
Boah, wie kann man das jetzt übersetzen.
Er hat überschätzt, was die Leute online, also den, er hat in Corona Zeit überschätzt,
wie viel die Leute online einkaufen, so sinngemäß.
Und deswegen hat er zu viele Leute eingekauft, eingestellt, investiert und jetzt hat er festgestellt,
das ist gar nicht so und jetzt muss er sie wieder alle rausschmeißen.
Ich hab auch gedacht, geile Begründung.
Random was gemacht, festgestellt, es taucht nicht, jetzt wieder alle rausgefeuert.
Er könnte sich ja feuern, ich glaube, das würden die meisten wahrscheinlich noch am
besten finden.
Fire Fat, ja.
Kennst du Vim Addons und so weiter?
Ich kenn jede Menge Vim Addons.
Aber ich kann dir nicht empfehlen, dein Vim zu einer IDE aufzumotzen.
Das heißt, das würde, wie heißt der Typ Prime, der Vim Hacker Man von YouTube Prime, Prime
Regen oder so?
Prime, Prime, Prime-A-Gen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den ausspricht.
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Wie spricht man den dann aus?
Der würde das wahrscheinlich anders sehen.
Da muss Vim quasi, muss dein Desktop ersetzen sozusagen.
Prime-A-Gen, okay.
So, zumindest, also ich hab das auch schon gemacht, ich bin damit durch.
Also ich hab auch schon mal eine Weile Emacs verwendet, wenn es um quasi Editor als Desktop-Ersatz
geht.
Also, ich hab das auch eine Weile gemacht.
Ich hab meinen Vim auch schon richtig krass aufgebohrt, ja, mit fuzzy search, Plugins,
allen möglichen Programmiersprachen, To-Do-Geschichten und alles Mögliche.
Aber ich hab festgestellt, dass das einfach eine viel, viel zu große Aufwand ist zu maintainen,
weil da machst du einmal ein Update, du hast ja dann irgendwann hast du 40 Plugins, machst
ein Update, irgendwas funktioniert in der Richtung, muss erst mal eine halbe Stunde suchen, du
hast eine ewig lange Vim-Config, wo du basteln musst und trotzdem viele Sachen klappen nach
wie vor nicht so gut.
Vielleicht ist das heute mit Language Server Support und Neo Vim alles ein Ticken besser,
mag sein.
Aber zum Beispiel gerade.NET in Vim zu machen war abartig, selbst mit den passenden Plugins.
War einfach nix.
Ich bin jetzt wieder dahin zurück, dass ich gesagt hab, wisst ihr was?
Ich verwende für Frontend Zeug und auch für, also ich verwende wirklich Studio Code und
irgendwie für.NET halt eine IDE.
Also ich verwende meistens JetBrains IDEs für die Sachen, wo es halt welche gibt, sei
es jetzt für Ruby oder für.NET oder für Python oder sonst was, verwende ich die passenden
JetBrains IDEs und für alles andere verwende ich Virtual Studio Code.
Virtual Studio Code kann man auch wunderbar customisern und hat gute Addons, gerade was
Microcontroller Sachen angeht, so Platform IOs finde ich somit das beste, was man da
benutzen kann eigentlich.
Aber dann ist gut, ja, Vim benutze ich auch täglich, allerdings nur als Kommandozahlen-Editor.
Und es ist gut, wenn man sich in Vim ein bisschen bewegen kann und auskennt, weil man das jeden
Tag gebrauchen kann, wenn man Remote PSSR aufwägen in der Kiste ist.
Leute, heute hab ich es übertrieben, wo wir gerade Remote bei Remote-Kisten sind.
Ich hab nicht mehr durchgeblickt.
Leute, ich hab T-Mux in T-Mux genestet und hatte überall so viele Tabs auf.
So, yo dog, I put a T-Mux in your T-Mux, then you can T-Mux while T-Mux.
Das war zu viel, da hab ich auch nicht mehr durchgeblickt, was was ist.
Hier noch ein cooler Battlefield Clip.
Der F-Operator, danke schön für die 18 Monate Subscription.
Schauen wir noch das.NET Video, ja, sollen wir das gucken heute?
Ich mein, nee, können wir nicht mal gucken.
Zu wenig Zeit.
Wenn ich in 30 Minuten Video guck, wisst ihr, es dauert vorneweg eine Stunde.
Also ich benutze für Frontend Sachen eigentlich ausschließlich Wischl Studio Code.
Ich also ich mein, muss sagen Frontend war damals Wim schon richtig gut.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man das auch als als Main Editor verwenden kann, ja.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Alter, was ist mit dem Flugzeug, was ist mit dem Heli los?
Fuck, Massive Massive FireCube Pilot hier, Moncastier.
Wo hab ich, wo hab ich mal Moncastier immer, ja.
Puff, genau.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Was heißt, das kann keine Absicht gewesen sein?
Ach, Chet, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn's Leute gibt, die nix anderes machen
als Helifliegen, dass sie so abartiges Zeug geübt haben.
Ach, der, der Schraubendreher, stimmt.
Wir wollten uns ja den Line des Tech Tips Schraubendreher Review angucken.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ist ja gar nicht so ne Ratsche ist das.
Also mich interessiert, ich, wir gucken uns das.
Hm.
Was könnte das mal für ein Video?
Ah, Top 50 Mario Songs ist Private.
Okay, Moncastier, na gut.
Ähm, haben wir Timestamps?
Irgendwo?
Nope.
Ich scroll mal, ich scroll mal kurz durch.
Also mich interessiert hauptsächlich, was er zu meinem sagt und was er zum Line des
Tech Tips Ding sagt.
Hast du Tipps, wie man Nervosität bei vor schnellen Gesprächen oder Prüfungen ablegen
kann?
Mal gucken, wie nervös ich am Montag bin, aber es ist wahrscheinlich wie bei allem Übung
macht den Meister, ja.
Und eine Sache, die hilft, also auch bei Präsentationen und sowas, gute Vorbereitung.
Wenn man selbst weiß, dass man ein bisschen geübt hat bzw. sich schon so ein paar Sachen
zurechtgelegt hat, geht man eh viel entspannter rein.
Deswegen, ich würde es auch nie wieder so machen wie früher beispielsweise, wenn ich
in der Schule Präsentationen machen musste.
Ich hab das gehasst, Präsentationen zu halten in der Schule.
Ich hab das nie gerne gemacht früher und dementsprechend waren die auch immer schlecht
und vor allem, warum waren die schlecht?
Weil ich das ignoriert hab.
Ich hab's verdrängt.
Ich hab quasi gedacht, oh fuck, am Montag oder am Dienstag muss ich irgendwas präsentieren
und ich hab mich damit überhaupt nicht beschäftigt, weil ich es so unangenehm fand und dementsprechend
war das dann so eine, wie sagt man so eine selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung.
Ich hatte keinen Bock drauf, weil es beschissen ist und es würde dann auch beschissen.
Und wenn man sich ein bisschen darauf vorbereitet und dementsprechend mach ich die, üblich
manche Präsentationen auch immer, wenn ich jetzt welche mache, übich die vorher auch
ein bisschen und dementsprechend klappt das ganz gut mittlerweile.
Mittlerweile mach ich es sogar ganz gerne.
Klar, mir hat's ein bisschen geholfen, muss ich auch jetzt sagen, dass ich seit 10 Jahren
YouTube Videos mache.
Das hat mir gar nicht so sehr geholfen, weniger nervös zu sein oder es sind eben so bessere
Präsentationen halten zu können.
Es gibt aber schon ein paar Punkte, wo mir das wirklich geholfen hat bei Präsentationen
und zwar sind das Denk-Pausen-Kaschieren.
Beschreib ich das, ich beschreib's mal so.
Also ihr kennt das vielleicht, ihr erzählt irgendwas und ihr wisst gerade gar nicht mehr
so 100% was kommt denn jetzt als nächstes.
Und dann müsst ihr normalerweise mal so 3-4 Sekunden kurz überlegen, war es das oder
das was als nächstes kommt.
Ahja, natürlich hilft das, wenn man das vorher geübt hat, weil wenn man vorher ein paar
mal die Sachen geübt hat, dann fällt es einem meistens relativ instinktiv ein dazu.
Aber eine Sache, die ich gemerkt habe, die mir YouTube Videos gebracht haben, sind wirklich
so Überleitungsdinger.
So beispielsweise ich sag unglaublich gerne sowas wie, ich sag bla bla bla und was auch
ganz wichtig ist, was man auch noch dazu sagen muss oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich hab so 4-5 Standard-Füllsätze, die ich mittlerweile komplett ohne Gehirn einen Satz
sagen kann und dann kann ich drüber nachdenken.
Schluck Wasser nehmen, kann man natürlich auch machen.
Aber ich hab so meine 3-4 Füllsätze, wenn ihr mal drauf achtet, es gibt so ein paar
Sachen, die sag ich total oft und das ist meistens, wenn ihr nicht weiß, was ich als
nächstes sagen soll.
Aber Vorbereitung ist wirklich alles und wenn du selbst was Gefühl hast, du hast schon ein
bisschen Ahnung von der ganzen Sache bzw. du hast dir schon Gedanken gemacht, mit was
man dich beispielsweise, wenn du dir jetzt schon mal Gedanken gemacht hast, was könnte
man dich dann fragen, wo du keine gute Antwort drauf hast, hast du schon mal viel gewonnen
und dann bist du gleich sicherer drin, zumal du dann auch schon vielleicht ein paar Themen
oder ein paar Sachen vorbereitet hast, die du sagen kannst, um eben so das Gesprächsthema
ein bisschen so dahin zu bringen, was dir lieber ist.
Also ein bisschen Gedanken vorher machen ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob ich montag aufgeregt bin.
Ich denke mal ein bisschen aufgeregt ist man immer.
Beim letzten Vorstellungsgespräch von vor ein paar Wochen her ging es.
Tatsächlich war ich nicht großartig aufgeregt.
Aber mal gucken.
Nee, habe ich nicht benutzt.
Bei 5.30 ungefähr gucken wir uns gleich an.
Stell dir eine Uhr hin, damit du...
Oh ja, das stimmt.
Gerade beim Üben ist das nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe meistens das Handy, also ich habe meistens die Stoppuhr an.
Wenn ich dann eine Präsentation vortrage, dann habe ich keine Stoppuhr mehr.
Aber gerade das stimmt schon, du hast recht.
Also gerade Zeit einschätzen, man überschätzt das teilweise maßlos.
Wenn man sich nämlich irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, machst ein paar Folien oder so am Rechner
und überlegst dir so, was sage ich das dazu und dann sage ich das dazu.
Man neigt dazu zu denken, man hat zu wenig.
Und ich habe es jetzt schon öfters gemerkt, dass man eigentlich viel länger braucht, wenn
man es wirklich mal hält oder mal wirklich versucht zu erzählen, als man gedacht hat.
Und dann kann man immer ganz gut, wenn man ein bisschen was kürzen kann.
Deswegen ist wichtig, dass man guckt, wie lange dauert es denn wirklich.
Guten Abend, ne nicht guten Abend, doch guten Abend zusammen guckst du Seven vs.
Wild.
Ne gucke ich nicht.
Ich weiß, was das ist.
Das ist irgendwie so ein YouTube Survival Show von Fritz Meinecke heißt das glaube ich.
Und da ist Reload Jack dabei und gewesen bei der ersten Staffel, das Einzige glaube ich,
den ich kannte davon.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung, kenne ich mich nicht mit aus.
Das musst du, da hast du recht Battleship.
Man sollte nicht gar zu klein lauter sein, so nach dem Motto nie was fragen, sondern sich
die ganze Zeit löchern lassen.
Weil wenn du dich die ganze Zeit löchern lässt, ist das blöde.
Denn irgendwann, früher oder später kommt mal irgendwas, wo du keinen Bock hast drüber
zu reden oder nicht genau weißt oder sonst was.
Selbst was fragen ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Das habe ich glücklicherweise bei meinem aller aller ersten Vorstellungsgespräch beim Provider
damals, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe, und zwar das aller aller erste Vorstellungsgespräch
war aber für die Physio Ausbildung, wo ich dann auch gekriegt habe, habe ich das aus
Versehen tatsächlich richtig gemacht.
Ich habe gleich irgendwas blödes gefragt.
Es war nichts blödes.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, so nach dem Motto, wenn ich fahre mal in ihre Unterhose, hätten
sie mich gleich wieder rausgeschmissen.
Beim Nachhinein, wenn ich mir an die Leute da denke, vielleicht, ne will ich gar nicht
wissen.
Aber ich habe am Anfang was zum, was vermeintlich blödes gefragt und dadurch hatte ich den
Vorteil, das Glück, dass es dann irgendwie 10 Minuten darum ging und so andere Sachen.
Das war tatsächlich ganz gut.
Da konnten sie mich nicht mit blödem Zeug fragen.
Blödem Zeug löchern.
Aha.
Ich kann jetzt dazu nichts sagen, aber ganz im Ernst, ich weiß nicht, ob irgendwelche
Mittel neben der beste Weg ist dagegen.
Also Vorbereitung und Erfahrung ist halt das, was sehr viel Nervosität rausnimmt.
Euch wird jeder sagen, ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, mit dem ich mich auch so ganz
verstehe, der spielt so hobbymäßig in so einer Cover Band und die sind schon öfters
aufgetreten.
Jetzt nicht riesengroß, sondern meist so irgendwie irgendwelche Pubs oder irgendwelche lokale
Beste oder so und er meint auch, egal wie oft er das macht, er ist jedes Mal aufgeregt
davor.
Obwohl er weiß, die können die Songs, obwohl er weiß, die Leute rennen ihm nicht weg,
wenn er singt, aber meint es trotzdem, er ist jedes Mal aufgeregt.
Und ich sag mal so, eine gewisse Nervosität ist auch gar nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man zu entspannt ist, ist auch nichts, weil eine gewisse Nervosität sorgt dafür,
dass man eben fokussiert ist und bei der Sache ist und man darf nichts, man darf nicht vergessen,
eine gewisse Anspannung hilft auch, dass man schneller denkt, nenne ich es jetzt einfach
mal.
Also wenn man ein bisschen angespannt ist, wie gesagt nicht wenn man so adrenalinmäßig
vollgepumpt ist, weil dann ist mit Denken gar nichts, aber wenn man ein bisschen angespannt
ist, wenn man weiß, so nach dem Motto, jetzt zählt es, dann ist man aufmerksamer, dann
ist man schneller beim Denken, in der Regel ist dann die Präsentation dadurch sogar
noch ein bisschen besser.
Wenn man natürlich komplett sich, wenn man schon Magenprobleme hat dadurch, wenn man
weiß gleich geht es los, das ist natürlich nicht gut, weil das sorgt dafür, dass man
wirklich nicht nachdenken kann.
Also es ist ja dann vergleichbar mit, du springst gerade ins Meer und stellst fest hinter dir
ist der Hai, da kannst du auch nicht wirklich gut denken dabei, dann hast du eher das Gefühl
Alter ich muss hier schnell weg, das hilft natürlich nicht gescheit zu denken, also
gewisse Anspannung ist aber nicht schlecht.
Und vorher mal aufs Klo gehen ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Und meistens geht das ja auch schlagartig weg, wenn man angefangen hat und dann bleibt
so diese Anspannung noch ein bisschen da und das hilft eigentlich, dass man sich besser
konzentrieren und besser denken kann.
Kann bei Schwäche, ja mal gucken ob die, ich bin mal gespannt was die mich fragen, da am
Montag.
Also ich werde sie auf jeden Fall auch ein paar Sachen fragen, so wie ist der aktuelle
Tech Stack oder solche Geschichten, so ein bisschen was rauskriegt und wo wir uns halt
einig werden müssen ist Homeoffice, also ich verlasse mich nicht auf die Aussagen, die
sagen zwar es ist 100% Homeoffice bzw. 99 bis irgendwie 1-2 Termine im Jahr Homeoffice,
aber eins habe ich gelernt bei der Firma wo ich aktuell arbeite, auf Aussagen das was
so sein wird kannst du dich nicht verlassen.
Also ich will Homeoffice im Vertrag drinstehen haben, dann ich kann damit leben wenn man irgendwie
eine schöne Formulierung findet, so nach dem Motto haupteinsatz, ich keine Ahnung rechtlich
habe ich keine Ahnung, aber wenn man sagt so ja Einsatzort ist irgendwie Remote aber
zu wichtigen Anlässen kann bis zu so und so viele tagen im Jahr auch Präsenz erforderlich,
das lasse ich mir gefallen aber es ist wichtig, dass da Homeoffice im Vertrag steht, damit
muss ich mich mit ihnen einig werden und halt letztendlich bei der Kohle muss ich mir einig
werden, aber was für eine Stelle hast du dich beworben?
Ist der witzig, ich habe gar keine Ahnung wie die das genau nennen, also ich kann dir
nur sagen das ist was in Richtung Senior DevOps Engineer ist, also es ist auf jeden Fall Senior
im Titel, kann ich dann sagen gut ich bin jetzt alt genug ich darf auch mal Senior im
Titel stehen haben, nicht dass es mich großartig interessieren wird, sowas in der Richtung,
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung wie es genau heißen wird, wo siehst du dich gehaltechnisch
habe ich am Anfang schon ein bisschen was zu erzählen, ich will es jetzt nicht gar
so ausbreiten vielleicht guckt jetzt noch irgend einer zu und die wissen dann was ich
sagen werde und für was ich dann machen würde und ja, also es darf schon ein bisschen mehr
sein als aktuell, weil letztendlich ja Homeoffice ist für mich ein Plus, aber ich bin, wenn
man sich mal anguckt was so das Durchschnittsgehalt in Frankfurt ist, so mit in dem Sektor mit
der Erfahrung und halt auch eben mit dem Fachbereich Gebiet ist das was wir verdienen jetzt nicht
so toll bei der Bank und dementsprechend was Inflation angeht und andere Geschichten das
dürfte ruhig da auch schon ein bisschen mehr sein, aber die kriegen sowas gar nicht auf
die Reihe außer wenn man sie regelmäßig nervt, ich meine ich habe die letzten Jahre
schon was gekriegt dank dem Einsatz von meinem Chef damals gab ja schon ein paar Sachen,
aber trotzdem könnte durchaus noch ein bisschen mehr sein und da muss man sich auch einig
werden wenn die jetzt sagen hey Homeoffice und es gibt noch mal einen Batzen mehr die
wissen natürlich nicht exakt was ich verdiene beim Alten das werde ich denen so auch nicht
sagen, dann ist halt die Frage was mich beim Alten noch hält, also wenn es mir da gefällt
wohlgemerkt muss natürlich auch gefallen da muss ich gucken also mal schauen ich werde
es euch berichten am Montagabend dann ich hatte einmal eine Gruppenpräsentation gehabt
mit mehreren Leuten auf einmal kam vorhin die ich nicht hatte das ist natürlich doof
und hat einfach weitergeredet bis mein Kollege kam und mich beiseite geschrummert jeder hatte
eine dass es genauso geplant war ja das hat er noch mal Glück gehabt natürlich blöd
ja kann schon mal kann schon mal gerade wenn man über Powerpoint in der Cloud editiert
dann kann da mit mehreren Leuten kann so was schon mal passieren ich habe letztens auch
zu was war das noch mal jetzt stehe ich gerade auf dem Schlauch was haben wir letztens gemacht
zu zweit den auf unsere Abteilungs Abteilungsrunde achso ja kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen im
Stream weil dann würde ich was über die Firma verraten Lull
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte wir haben ja auch eine Präsentation gehalten und ich
habe die Einleitung diesmal tatsächlich komplett verkackt ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
dass es wieder komplett in die Hose gegangen und zwar aber da hat es tatsächlich ein bisschen
die Erfahrung aus YouTube Videos gemacht ich habe konnte mich da relativ easy easy raus
reden das hat eigentlich kaum einer gemerkt dass es richtig also doch man hat gemerkt
dass es verkackt war aber es kam jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig negativ rüber also wir
haben die Präsentation konnten starten also das war eine größere Runde das war eine
größere Runde das war eine übergreifende Abteilungsleiter Gruppenleiter Runde also
sprich da waren jetzt keine großartigen Techniker da sondern eher irgendwelche Anzug Management
Leute inklusive unserem obersten IT Typ so und wir haben da was vorgestellt was wir was
wir tolles gemacht haben so die letzten paar Jahre über zumindest wir werden eingeladen
in die Besprechung das war remote bei Teams ja Kollege und ich und ich habe das intro
gemacht und ihr werdet es nicht glauben BWL auch auch auch BWL dabei ich habe angefangen
zu erzählen also ich hatte Kamera an hatte mein hatte mein Headset auf und ihr kennt
das Headset ja ich habe euch das ja schon mal in der Kamera gezeigt ich habe ja einen
selbstgebauten Pop Schutz auf meinem Headset drauf also so gelber so aus dem gelben Schwamm
habe ich mir den eigenen Pop Schutz ausgeschnitten so und während ich die Präsentation auf
so ein Schwamm aus dem Schwamm habe ich mir den Pop Schutz rausgeschnitten Leute beste
sieht ungefähr so aus Pop Schutz selber machen Pop Schutz selber bauen
Nein so sieht das nicht aus ist auch egal ich habe einen selbstgebauten Pop Schutz und
er sieht halt in der Kamera immer recht auffällig aus und jeder der mich zum ersten mal sieht
in der Kamera und mein Headset sieht fragt was ist das für eine Kartoffel oder ihr macht
irgendeinen blöden lustigen Spruch und ich habe mir halt was wollte ich sagen ja wie gesagt
ich habe mir halt selbst einen Pop Schutz gebaut so und ich habe halt während ich die
Präsentation geöffnet habe man kommt dann ins Team rein Teams rein sagt er erstmal
hallo macht die Präsentation auf und während ich die Präsentation geöffnet habe habe
ich halt erzählt es muss keiner fragen das ist ein selbstgebauter Pop Schutz also irgendwie
keine Kartoffel oder sonst wie ich sag es einfach nur weil ich weiß dass das ehe gefragt
wird nur so bevor wir anfangen dass nicht alle irritiert gucken müssen jetzt die ganze
Präsentation lang und dann habe ich die Präsentation aufgemacht und da hat noch haben Leute gesagt
so wie das funktioniert habe ich gesagt ja super viel besser als von was fertig gekauft
ist von Amazon und jetzt kommt in dem Moment wo ich die Präsentation aufgemacht habe
und als ich gesagt habe viel besser als von Amazon in dem Moment geht mein Headset aus
also Teams Teams hat mein Input Channel geswitcht aus irgendwelchen Gründen das macht Teams
normalerweise nie das ist glaube ich ein Bug wenn man Powerpoint Präsentationen aufmacht
und in dem Moment hört mich keiner mehr in dem Moment hört mich keiner mehr zum Glück
hat mein Kollege gleich geschaltet hat gemeint ja siehst du mal das funktioniert oder sehen
immer es funktioniert so gut dass das das von schon gar nichts ist rauscht so wenig dass
man gar nichts hört war nicht weiter schlimm ich musste dann aufs Handy schalten mit Lautsprecher
und Kamera weil mein Headset ja nicht ging und dann musste ich mich immer oder mein Kollege
immer selbst muten und so hin und jetzt will die Katze wieder raus
so zumindest da musste ich mich immer selbst muten und so es war ganz eklig in der Handhabung
dann über die über die Helden weil ansonsten habe ich mich doppelt gehört über die Handykamera
so ganz ganz eklig zumindest habe ich dementsprechend danach die Einleitung ziemlich verkackt ja
eigentlich wollten wir uns kurz kurz vorstellen weil wir in der Runde noch nicht gewesen sind
und dann wollte ich erzählen um was es geht und ich habe einfach nur ganz kurz gesagt
ja wir sind da und dieses Thema und Agenda für heute und als ich dann beim zweiten Punkt
von der Agenda war ist mir aufgefallen wir haben das Intro gar nicht gemacht wir haben
weder gesagt von welchem normalerweise immer solche Runden geht sagt man immer aus welchem
Team man kommt und wer man ist weil Namen und und so ist er immer ganz wichtig und wir
haben gar nichts großartig gemacht ja und das ist mir dann wirklich im zweiten Punkt
von der Agenda war eingefallen dass ich das Intro total verkackt habe aber irgendwie habe
ich es dann doch doch noch hingedreht ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich gesagt habe irgendwas
blödes über mein Headset glaube ich noch mal gesagt und bin dann noch mal eine Folie
zurück ja genau ich weiß was ich gesagt habe ich weiß was ich gesagt habe ich habe gesagt
ja wenn man mich schon nicht hört dann sollte man wenigstens wissen wen man nicht hört
und bin irgendwie noch mal eine Folie zurück irgendwie sowas in der Richtung und dann
haben wir es dann habe ich quasi noch mal die Intro folie fortgesetzt und ja und das
ist tatsächlich was was mir so YouTube Videos wirklich gebracht haben dass mir so Sachen
besser einfallen auch irgendwie wenn man ein bisschen nervös ist und unter Druck und
sowas vorstellt zumindest bin ich zurückgegangen auf die ja ja smooth bin ich noch mal auf
die Intro Folie zurück und haben wir uns vorgestellt dann wussten die das auch und
dann war alles gut restliche Präsentation war super danach haben sich auch alle noch
bedankt so ja dieses Thema dass man das jetzt auch mal näher erfährt ganz toll ja da haben
sich alle gefreut lief dann richtig gut hast du jetzt etwas mit fulltime home office wenn
ich da hingehe dann nur mit fulltime home office das bleibt tatsächlich in den ja ist
wirklich so ich muss jetzt kurz ein bisschen hin und her springen wo sind wir wo sind
verstehend geblieben hier irgendwo ganz kurz dazu wollte ich was sagen und zwar sowas
bleibt den kopf hängen tatsächlich ich habe gehört dass es ein paar tage später schon
so ein bisschen der running gag war wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert so nach dem motto hast
du auch ein schwamm oder sowas das muss da wohl die runde gemacht haben jetzt wohl schon
so der running gag aber ganz ehrlich ganz ehrlich kann nur gut sein für mich wenn man
sich auf management ebene lustig macht über headsets und schwämme und dinge die nicht
funktionieren dann ist wenigstens was hängen geblieben soll mir recht sein so wo bin ich
denn stehen geblieben leute ich komme halt hier überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht mehr
genau der schwammtüp will mehr geld das wissen die gleich wer gemeint ist auf was für eine
stelle hast du nicht bewohnt also habe ich ja gerade schon beantwortet denkst du dass
home office trend durch mask wieder zurückgezogen wird nee denke ich nicht aus mehreren gründen
der erste grund ist man hat gesehen also klar irgendwelche super boomer management gibt
es nach wie vor die da keinen bock drauf haben und bei uns wie gesagt da wo ich gerade
arbeite ist auch schwieriges thema aber aus zwei also aus zwei gründen erstens man hat
die letzten jahre übergesehen es funktioniert wunderbar das zweite ist es werden händenring
it experten und fachleute gesucht und die firmen wissen dass sie das anbieten müssen
wenn sie gute leute bekommen wollen ganz einfach der trend wird nicht wieder zurückgehen
ich glaube das ist eine bleibende sache auch für die zukunft die wir indirekt tatsächlich
corona zu verdanken haben weil viele unternehmen in deutschland haben erst in der corona zeit
weil sie mussten angefangen sich ums thema homeoffice gedanken zu machen und das ist
tatsächlich was was wir indirekt corona zu verdanken haben deine neue stelle heißt blazing
die fast full stack de vop senior engineer moment moment moment def sec ops wenn schon
da lege ich wert drauf also der rest ist ok aber da muss noch ein sektor zwischen blazing
die fast full stack def sec ops senior der senior muss dann anfangen blazing die fast
senior full stack def sec ops engineer full stack die was auch immer ja muss ja muss schon
alles rein naja komm wir müssen es mal nicht übertreiben da müsste ich da müsste ich
bei bei microsoft oder so arbeiten die bezahlen er fett geholt also 150 ist dann doch schon
ein bisschen viel wollte jetzt mal nicht total übertreiben immer nehmen würde ich das alles
so ist es nicht ich würde nicht sagen bleibt man fort mit mehr geld aber ganz ehrlich
bei vier tagen ist es eh weniger und mal ganz davon abgesehen es ist jetzt ja auch
nicht so als als als wäre ich am verhungern oder so aber ich trotzdem muss ich sagen ich
sehe es aktuell nicht ein dass wenn man das mal mit frankfurter durchschnittsgehalten
sagen vergleich dass es dass sie das so billig kriegen also da muss schon ordentliches gehalt
drin sein und ich meine ich habe immer den noch den riesen vorteil dass ich mit youtube
und twitch ein bisschen geld verdiene und wenn ich mehr sell outs mache dann auch ganz
ok also der genshin sell out hat sich ganz gut gelohnt und der ich habe schon wieder
vergessen wie es hieß nicht coin master match master sell out hat sich auch gelohnt es
kommt jetzt es kommt jetzt noch ein video am samstag wahrscheinlich und dann gibt es
tatsächlich dann darauf am 18 wahrscheinlich noch mal ein sell out video aber diesmal mit
gaming hardware die heizung bezahlt sich nicht alleine und die 40 90 auch nicht ja das ist
halt das was ich wirklich sehr zu schätzen gelernt habe die letzten jahre über es ist
unglaublich beruhigend wenn man weiß man muss weder das eine noch das andere machen
also wenn die mir auf der arbeit zu sehr auf den sack gehen könnte ich theoretisch von
heute auf morgen sagen macht es gut was ich vertraglich nicht kann aber nummer rein vom
geld her könnte ich erstmal von heute auf morgen sagen leckt mich kein bock mehr erstens
habe ich genug geld noch so auf dem konto in den letzten jahren und im zweifelsfall kann
ich einfach auch ein bisschen mehr auch was youtube und twitch angeht machen damit komme
ich auf jeden fall erstmal ganz gut über die runden wenn ich wenn ich da wirklich mehr
machen würde oder umgedreht könnte ich auch sagen ich mache es einfach mal ein halbes
jahr kein youtube twitch und verdiene auch so genug also das ist tatsächlich sehr angenehm
und das beste ist jetzt wenn ich wenn ich den neuen job suche ja dass ich selbst da
jetzt nicht gezwungen bin ja es ist nicht so dass ich sagen muss ich brauche jetzt unbedingt
neuen job ich kann mir das angucken wenn mir das gefällt home office technisch gehaltstechnisch
und der laden an sich kann ich sagen mache ich oder ich bleibe einfach da wo ich bin
vielleicht machen die auch ein gutes gegen angebot kann ja auch sein weil ich nicht weiß
ob ich da bleiben will würdest du 100 prozent arbeiten unter nur vier tage nur vier tage
100 prozent werde ich nie wieder machen never ich habe das aber auch nur gemacht beziehungsweise
überhaupt auf die dge kommen weil ich ein youtube video zugesehen habe ansonsten ist
ja simpel schwamm gekauft von amazon so ein auto reinigung schwamm und dann mit einem
teppichmesser so ein popschutz rausgeschnitten wurde wo das headset mikro reinpasst
der fzgit chat ops ja da könnte man sich schon eher mit anfreunden kein agile und cloud
native doch das muss auch noch rein agil und play sing die fast was ist das kling ich
jetzt nicht an meine vorschau funktioniert nicht mit dem schwamm ich habe mir den eigenen
popschutz aus dem schwamm gebaut und ich wusste eine präsentation halten auf der
arbeite was heißt ich musste eigentlich stimmt das gar nicht ich habe mir das ja sogar noch
freiwillig eingebrockt ich habe gesagt wäre das nicht mal eine gute idee das vorzustellen
das fanden alle eine gute idee und dann habe ich vorgestellt so ich habe einen schwamm
gebaut als pop aus dem schwamm und popschutz für mein headset gebaut und ich habe eine
präsentation halten müssen auf der arbeit remote über teams und in dem moment wo ich
gesagt habe dass das ein selbstgebauter popschutz ist und er viel besser ist als das teusch was
man so von amazon kaufen kann das habe ich gesagt weil ich die frage immer kommt wenn
mich einer in der kamera sieht ist mein headset kaputt gegangen in teams das war halt ein
blöde blöde blödes timing ja und jetzt ist das quasi auch schon da ein bisschen zum
running gag geworden dass sachen kaputt und schwamm aber ein headset ist gar nicht kaputt
gewesen es war nur teams was den input channel geswitcht hat weil ich grad weil ich die präsentation
geöffnet habe sie in teams back wie gesagt würde ich nicht mehr vier tage vier tage
woche ist das maximum was ich machen würde schwamm drüber ja ok also was wollte ich
jetzt noch ganz schnell gucken was sagen die zu dem linus tech tips habe ich jetzt schon
wieder geschlossen ja was sagen die zu dem linus tech tips screwdriver zeigt mal her bei
vierfünfzig oder so ist es angeblich ist er ist ja enthusiastisch über über raschen
und schrauben dreher
jetzt will er sagen ok wir es gibt mal ein bisschen vor bleck und decker sata heißt das
ding wirklich sata
china china is ein zeug oder ok also wo ist der
klar
ist das der linus tech ne wo ist er denn was ist das für ein teil ok vera was sagt das
so das vera ding habe ich gesehen ich mag ja normalerweise vera also vera werkzeug aber
der hat mich nicht so angesprochen
wo ist er wo ist er in der linus tech tips ist er das ist er das ist er das schon
also wie gesagt ich habe den pb swiss tool der kommt ja dann auch noch irgendwo das aber
nicht der den ich habe meiner hat einen schwarzen griff und ist ein anderer aber guck mal was
er dazu sagt
ok hört sich schon mal relativ fein zahnig anfängt ganz gut
ich würde interessieren wie lose der ist beim hin und her drehen wenn es auf wenn es gelockt
ist
wie viel hat der drin ok wo ist meiner das ist nicht meiner leute das ist ein anderer
das ist ein pb 850 10r 100 was ist der unterschied ok moment moment moment moment was ist der
unterschied da reden der pb swiss tool er versus und dann gibt es ja auch den ganzen
noch mit 800 ach also das sind ja produktnamen wirklich ok was ist was ist in der unterschied
dazwischen warum kennst du den namen dann schreibe ich kenne nicht aus wenn ich hab
den vorhin abgeschrieben ist da irgendwie für elektronik sachen ok was ist der unterschied
hier dazwischen das ist den ich hab und das ist das ist der andere kostet der vielleicht
ist es was mit euch los ne ok das schon besser was ist der unterschied hier dazwischen
10 in one tool ach der hat keine tools hinten der hat keine klappe hinten drin oder und
der ist kürzer der ist kürzer der hat keine schrauben mit dabei oder du hast auch den
der ist der ist richtig nice ja also der ist den erst gleich lang was man viel hat verbraucht
kann ich aus dem kopf gar nicht sagen ok ich weiß ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wo
genau der unterschied da jetzt ist keine ahnung das ist der twister und das ist der was zum
ok leute ich weiß nicht genau was der unterschied ist aber scheinen unterschied zu geben
wie das ist wie die dinger da hinten drin sind oder der hier ist zum rausdrehen und
der andere ist zum klappen kann das sein ok fazit
wir gucken mal fazit an ja seht ihr easy war wieder das beste gekauft easy kostet aber
danach kommt gleich der linus tech tips ok ok meiner kostet auch als doppelte ja der
war schlecht ja kann sein ist der hat mich auch überhaupt look ich sprach so wackelig
aus den die die vorrichtung da hast du einen neuen job am mordag vorstellungsgespräche
am montag ich müssen nachgucken ich weiß es nicht ich habe keine ahnung aus dem kopf
juckt mich auch nicht so wirklich ich lade half wenn ich unter 40 prozent bin in hoch
und und aufgeladen was ist welchen hast du du hast du den hast du den den roten oder
den schwarzen ich habe den schwarzen den den eher 600 er 6000 110 oder so
Ja
Kann man machen klar wenn du ab und zu mal einmal im jahr irgendwie eine schraube reindrehst ist das in ordnung
Aber gerade die billigen die franzen relativ schnell aus und wenn du mal ordentlich an was dran drehen musst
Ist zumindest mal ein
stabiler bitt
vorne drin nicht verkehrt falls es einer ist mit austausch austauschbaren bits
Durchbrechen wirst du den nicht wobei ich habe schon geschafft bei einem billigen china chinesen das weiß ich noch bei so einem billigen china
Schraubenzieher habe ich schon mal den griff abgemacht war so ganz billig das ding ganz billig ist mit so gegossenem plastik griff so was ganz billiges
Aber muss sagen arbeiten mit ordentlichem werkzeug macht auch mehr spaß als mit billig werkzeug
Zumindest nicht desto trotz eine sache die jeder daheim haben sollte
meiner ansicht nach
Wenn man ein bisschen was macht ist ein aggro schrauber aggro schrauber ist einfach wirklich so ein komplettes
Universal ding was man immer brauchen kann damit kannst du löcher in die wand bohren
Also man braucht keine bohrmaschine um löcher in die wand zu bohren gerade hier in der wohnung in drinnen kanns mit aggro
Schrauber ohne probleme gerade wenn der zwei gänge hat dass du ein bisschen höhere drehtal machen kannst
kannst löcher in die wand bohren kannst
schrauben machen
und alles also aggro aggro schrauber ist beste
also billig also billig 12 volt aggro schrauber reicht komplett aus also was ich was ich gut finde ist hier diesen
im set
im set mit den
nein nicht das
im set
Mit den bohrern so ja das hier ist das hier ist sehr nicht gut
das hier ist das hier ist sehr nice das teil
Gsr
Das ist wahrscheinlich die ältere die ältere variante davon gehen wir von aus
Das ist ein gsr der gsr ist ohne extra bohrfunktion
Aber das braucht man auch nicht die bohrfunktion ist eigentlich total unsinnig also das ist ein gutes set
Super super schrauben super aggro schrauber und du hast auch so die allnötigsten sachen dabei
Also aggro schrauber kann ich wirklich jedem empfehlen der noch keinen hat kann man immer gebrauchen und ansonsten was auch praktisch ist wenn man sonst nichts hat
und einfach
bisschen werkzeug und bits braucht für alles
dieses wäre komplett set das ist klein kompakt
Und du hast so ziemlich alles was du brauchst von talks wobei
Man sagt ja wie sagt man einen innen sechs kant oder so heißt das ja glaube ich wenn man
Korrekt ist oder oder es ist wieder was anderes also alles von von talks bis
Diese komischen
Sicherheitsding alles möglich dabei und du hast auch ein paar nüsse wenn du mal
Was schrauben muss wo halt keine normale schraube dran ist also das ding ist wirklich praktisch
Und das in kombination mit dem aggro schrauben hast du echt alles was du so brauchst für 95 prozent der sachen daheim
Das fix it kit ist auch nicht schlecht gerade wenn man wenn man elektronik zeug und rechner zeug macht ist auch okay
Das ist eh mehr oder weniger das gleiche
Das ist alles so drechen rechentrick ob 12 oder 14 volt sind 13, er ist was
Innen sechs kant genau
Zumindest macht es mir Spaß mit ordentlichen werkzeug zu werken
Ja und in kombination wenn man schon gerade dabei ist was ich auch sehr praktisch finde wenn man sich diesen bosch 12 volt kauft
Kann man sich auch noch die led lampe kaufen
Da passen nämlich die gleichen akkus rein
Und das ding macht richtig hell man kann es hinstellen man kann es an einem griff aufhängen das hat oben so ein hacken
Habe ich beispielsweise schon total auf dem keller gehalten
Keller letztens wieder meine konstruktion repariert ich habe doch ich habe im keller doch eine
Ich habe sowas im keller sieht so ähnlich aus ja ich habe so ein teil was
automatisch die den wasserhahn aufmachen kann wasserhahn auf und zu machen kann du hast recht stripes du hast recht was du hast
Das kann automatisch den wasserhahn für den heizungsdruck auf und zu machen im keller
Sieht so ähnlich aus wie das nur mit dem unterschied dass das so nicht direkt rangepasst hat bei mir deswegen habe ich
Den den hebel für das ventil habe ich verlängert mit einem slot blech vom computer
Mit so einem mainboard slot blech habe ich den habe ich den verlängert und habe
Ja da was drumherum gemacht dass es nicht dass es nicht abgeht und letztens
Ist einer dran hängen geblieben und hat es abgemacht und das muss ich jetzt mal sehen
Oder ist ziemlich dusch im keller habe ich die lampe hinter mich habe ich die lampe hinter mich gehängt habe das wieder dran dran geschraubt und gut ist
Also lampe ist wirklich gold wert wenn man ordentliche lampe hat
Ja gut genug werkzeug kram nicht stierndampe ohne mist ich habe eine ganze weile stierndampe verwendet
Stierndampe haben vorteile die man sich nicht so gut verändern kann
Die stierndampe ohne mist ich habe eine ganze weile stierndampe verwendet stierndampe haben vorteile haben auch nachteile
Ich persönlich mag stierndampe nicht so sehr nicht weil man die auf dem kopf hat das ist nicht so wild
sondern weil manchmal
Der winkelkacke ist also wenn man von vorne auf was drauf guckt und nicht viel licht drumherum ist
Und je nachdem wie die form ist kann das sein
Dass man gerade dann dadurch schatten drauf wirft
Weil man das ding direkt von vorne anleucht also man man scheint von vorne man leuchtet von vorne drauf
Und dann ist halt irgendwas zwischen dort wo du schrauben willst und dann fällt dir genau dadurch der schatten da drauf wo du schrauben willst
Also deswegen finde ich stierndampe gar nicht mehr so praktisch ich hänge mir lieber schräg daneben
Diese diese 12 volt bosch lampe und dann ist das ding auch richtig hell
gut nicht dassotrotz leute
Ich wollte euch eigentlich gute nachtmusik anmachen
Wir sehen uns spätestens montag ein die sonntag morgens zum aufwachen
Und sonntag montag abend erzähle ich euch wie das vorstellungsgespräch gelaufen ist
Vielleicht bin ich morgen abend oder samstag auch am start
Samstag kann durchaus sein samstag müssen wir amazon zeug programmieren stimmt samstag also wir sehen uns samstag wir sehen uns sonntag morgens und wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich montag abend
Leute wir sehen uns macht's gut bis denn
zu
Also
Das war's für heute.
jer- dever-